e
okay the time being 10:05 we'll get
started I'm going to open the public
hearing on hb720
28 and representative om will introduce
the
Bill thank you Mr
chairman I'm introducing house bill
number 728 FN authorizing video loty
Lottery terminals at charity Gaming
facilities and repealing historic horse
racing
licensing okay would you like to say
anymore would you take questions I'll
I'll defer to the prime sponsor who uh
has a lot of comments on this I will say
that the bill itself does a change in
the split between the operators take and
the take of the uh Charities and the
take of New Hampshire the HHR bill that
we've have in statute give 75% of the
take to the operator and 25% of the take
to the uh State of New Hampshire to be
split up under current law the new bill
highp 728 changes the machines from what
I think are basically off trck betting
terminals horse racing terminals into
true video Lottery terminals true slot
machines as part of that process the
bill will give an additional take to the
state it reduces the take from the
operator from 75% to 70% and increases
the take to the state from 25 to
30% okay thank
you I know that you're not you're not
the uh sponsor of this so I don't think
we'll unless represent El may have a
question uh just of you are we not going
to be able to talk to representative
duet about this bill uh we may not be
able to so we will hear from uh other
testimony for now
all right thank you representative
M uh next we will uh hear from former
State Rep Pat brammy welcome back to
means thank you Mr
chair uh I was minding my own business
yesterday at about four o'clock I just
went into the calendar and said uh
what's going on in Ways and Means
because I was just like keeping track
then I saw this Bell I said you know I
really should should show up given that
I as well first off pamy former State
Rep six terms wayy means for 12 years
and also uh was chair of the charitable
gaming study commission as you all know
because I've been here before on this I
put before you a a handout which would
be important to follow along with
especially the first
page um and I guess I'll I thought I was
going to repeat what Fred was going to
say but I guess Fred's I just found out
just a minute ago that Fred took a job
elsewhere so
um so as as you know we had a consultant
spectrum and in in that report it said
that you know uh New Hampshire it's
costing you 12 to 18% more in expense to
have these historic racing
machines uh because of the fees
associated with the uh the total lator
fees which are the the thing that
calculates the winnings like any other
track
race and the uh and the fees that go to
the tracks because this whole concept
was was founded by uh folks in Kentucky
who know that racing is dying and they
were looking for another source of
Revenue so all those historic Races they
charge for those so there's a fee in
between this is from the consultant
about you know 12 to
18%
so we wasn't our charge to really be
looking at do we convert for as a
commission do from historic racing to
slot machines I'm calling a slot
machines the vernacular okay there's
other language in here uh I'm just using
the vernacular uh slot machines
everybody knows so um so I took a look
at the Bell last night and my wife said
what are you
doing we used to have dinner at a
certain time he said well give me
another
hour um I'm going to put something
together here and I I I reviewed the
bill and I had some questions uh but I
also wanted to share my understanding of
the bill uh and just and I'm glad I'm
here because uh the prime sponsor isn't
here and again I didn't know he took
another job so in the first page um I
think representative OLS touched on
it I said who's the beneficiary of the
of the uh gross uh Gaming revenue the
gross Gaming revenue is the revenue
all the payouts okay whether it's table
games or or the machine
games so yes the facilities were getting
75% of the of the revenue but now with
this new bill they would only get 70% as
representative om mentioned and I have a
footnote and I'm going to explain that
in a second Charities go from 8.33% to
10.5% or Plus
2.17 lottery
uh which is really goes to the education
fund eventually goes from 16.67% to 18%
or an increase of
1.33% problem gaming nothing came from
it other than problem gaming was funded
by breakage from historic racing bracing
breaking is a is a horse racing term for
the when they when they settle out any
any uh
rounding goes to the facility okay but
what we did in historic racing has
pointed that breakage to problem gaming
and I have some comments on that as well
and then the new the new wrinkle is that
uh uh the sponsor of the bill decided
that group a retirement should be a
beneficiary of 1.42 five% of the of the
gain so let's look at foot number
one so the consultant report said that
55% of table game
Revenue uh that went to facilities was
low so they said that was low
but then they said 75% of HHR Revenue
going to facility was high as compared
to slot
machines using HHR machines instead of
slot machines cost the facility
12.18% more because of totalizer and
historic racing fees to tra uh to to the
tracks also there are only four there
are only four manufacturers of historic
racing machines and there 12
manufacturers of slot machines and what
we found out from the the commission was
that uh the given that there's not very
lack of competition in that that market
of HHR machines that the the facilities
can get a better deal with slot machines
just from a sheer competition
standpoint so even though the percentage
of gross Gaming revenue is reduced by
5% facilities benefit because their
operating cost will go down remember
doing with those fees helps first the
facilities they do not get the they they
they're going to they're going to run
these machines without having to pay the
the cost of the all those fees for the
totalizer and for the uh historic racing
fees to the tracks and then there's
better competition they get better they
can get better prices on the slot
machines than they can with HHR machines
because of the
competition so so yes they're they're
getting uh 5% less but in the same
breath I will say that remember the
Consultants report said that um that the
uh table game revenues were lower to the
facilities than a normal that they see
out there so I think in Balance I I'm
not going to you know I'm not going to
address whether it's a good idea to go
to Group B retirement or wherever you
want to allocate the money but I think
representative own touched on it it's
really really two things what goes to
facilities and what goes to the state
and what the state does with allocating
that money is up to you folks okay uh
and uh so and if in
that what I just said in in the footw
one is in the recommendation 12 of the
of the of the report uh if you want to I
don't know if you ever got the report
out there everybody but that's what that
is so for Charities Charities gain uh 2.
17% in this B in this bill the way
written uh and again the the commission
report recommendation
12 said
that said that Charities and the state's
revenues will increase and they will and
let me read let me read let me read uh
recommendation 12 again this wasn't on
our radar screen but we took it up
because of the consultant's report the
question that we pose to the commission
was should New Hampshire switch from HHR
machines to stop
machines and here's what here's the
here's the dialogue that went on as
mentioned before the Spectrum report
indicates that facilities are paying 12
to 18% of
ggr uh gross Gaming revenue more for HHR
machines because of the totalizer and
historic racing fees that do not exist
in slot machines in addition there are
only four HHR manufacturers and close to
a dozen slot machine manufacturers so
cost of compet competitive competition
the least costs of for HH machines are
higher than slot machines as discussion
evolved in the commission there was a
recognition that leg the legislature
went with HHR machines when we did in
the first place since there wasn't much
support for slot machines I'm just being
honest here at the time the fact that
HHR machines have a about a 5-second
delay between plays was enough to win
support in the legislature and what I
mean there
is okay these machines are really
designed for people to pull down a
screen and to look at the race and to
see the record of the horse not the name
of the horse the record of the of the uh
jockey not the name of the Jockey and to
make a reason decision about which which
horse you're going to say he going to
win place you know
whatever I've observed
over my years since that went in uh
through my commission work going to
various facilities nobody plays it that
way Everybody Plays the auto playay like
they're playing a slot
machine and and that's just the way it
is and I've talked to owners of these
facilities and they concur that that's
basically the way people play so moving
from uh from a from a from a from the
poent from the standpoint of the user
they think they're playing slot machines
anyway okay
so uh but that 5sec delay is because of
the the calculation that has to be made
at the after the BET after the after the
button is pushed and the winner is the
winners are chosen then it has a slight
delay to do that totalizer work that
needs to be done to calculate the
payouts
okay uh but 5 seconds but this is what
the commission said the deliberative we
called it I call it the speed and they
they Chang it to Del velocity the
deliberative velocity of play of these
machines was still attractive to many on
the
commission meaning they wanted to stay
with HHR also discussed was whether it
was too soon to consider changing to the
facil uh to the uh slot machines but
there was a consensus that moving to
slot machines would increase revenues to
the facilities the Charities and the
state and as you can see this bill that
does happen okay
so
um so that's that one and then for uh
the lottery and it which basically the
net most of the lottery net goes to all
of the lottery net goes to the education
fund so that went up 1.3% and basically
I I would point you to the commission
report again uh
12 I talked about
breakage um and let me read my my
footnote
for with HHR machines bra breaka was the
source of revenue for problem
gaming the commission study discovered
that only one vendor had the capacity to
calculate the breakage big problem four
vendors only one was calculating it only
one V only one vendor was contributing
to the
fund this issue was placed on the ACT we
didn't have enough time to resolve that
so this issue was placed on the action
list for the follow-up commission to
address which you all voted for there's
a follow-up commission and we had a long
list of things that we recommended
needed to to continue on if this bill
passes there will be a more steady flow
of problem Garing funds doing it this
way and it'll be and I don't I don't
have the raw numbers I don't there was
no fiscal note but it'll be substantial
even though it sounds like a small
percentage it'll be it'll be a
substantial amount that it will go to
the problem gaming fund and we had a
whole secondary study done on like I
mentioned last time on problem gaming
and there's a lot of work that needs to
be done on problem gaming not just from
the terrible gaming but from all of the
betting that goes on in the state um and
that that was also in our report that
this follow-up commission should really
be addressing a a better structure for
for problem
gaming so um but this problem of
breakage if you go to S machines goes
away it goes away so I guess that's a
benefit if if we go sub machines this
breakage issue is is not no longer an
issue and then we have also have a
better stream of
Revenue so on the fifth point about
Group
B uh again I just simply say that it's
up to ways of me to decide what a
reasonable allocation should be so
there's couple of two other points I
want to make um one the other issue that
needed to be
solved was between slot machines and HHR
machines which is is recommendation 20
report let me let me read recommendation
20 um and this came up this issue came
up from our uh Assistant Attorney
General who was on the
commission okay so the question we posed
to our commission members uh this is the
way I did it as chair I I POS the
question and then we have the discussion
then we come to a
conclusion do we agree with the spectum
report that our gaming oh one r one r 20
is there an undue economic concentration
of HHR machine manufacturers currently
functioning in New Hampshire
Market the commission discussed whether
the
legislature should consider economic
concentration among the manufacturers of
historic racing machines the evidence
suggests that only two manufacturers of
HHR machines control almost the entire
Market if you looked at it I mean one is
the real dominant there's one that's
kind of a moderate and the other two are
very very little so it's really really
one maybe one and a half of the vendors
that of their machines that are in
place
um again for the whole state suggesting
a afka competition and a neom
monopolistic status over a significant
portion of gaming within the state the
commission recommends legislation to
remedy this consistent with article
83 of the New Hampshire Constitution and
you the last page of what I handed out
has as article 83 and I underlined the
the the relevant Pace free and Fair
competition in trades and industries is
an inherent and essential right of the
people and should be protected against
all monopolies and um and uh
conspiracies which tend to Hinder or
destroy it so uh so this was another
thing that we were suggesting be taken
up by the by the follow-up commission
and or by the
legislature uh but again if we do away
with HHR this goes away as
well
so and then the last
thing is I was wanted to make sure and I
didn't have time to I read the Bell
twice I didn't really have a time to
study it um but my
interpretation facilities phasing out of
HHR slot machines I'm
um uh page five of the Bell lines 20 to
22 if you look at the effective
dates it says section one of this act
shall take effect upon
passage which puts in place all the
language in section one which is all the
slot machine language okay and then the
remainder of this act shall take effect
January 1
2028 so I a three years and that does
away with all of the all of the HHR
language okay that goes away so my
interpretation is it seems like slot
machines can start being phased out upon
passage of section one
it seems like HHR machines need to be
phased out by January 1st
2028 when all other sections of the
spill are eliminated in from section six
and then I concluded well it seems like
in the inter room between when and it's
on the effective date okay uh it's the
uh phas out upon passage between upon
passage to January 1st of
2028 I think what I think what the bill
is saying is that we can during the
inter room that these machines can be
phased out and phased
in okay there's a three-year people up
to the facility what they want to do
they want to start phasing out their
their uh historic racing machines they
can at a certain pace and start putting
them putting in HHR uh slot machines
they can it's up to them uh they can
choose in the in this period it can't be
instantaneous but let's say they want to
get rid of all their HHR machines they
can do this probably in a couple of
months or for probably half a year and
have all slot machines up to them that
is my
interpretation I was going to ask the
prime sponsor if that was his
interpretation but anybody here can help
me I I I just put that out as a question
that needs to be verified okay so that's
what I have thank you sir thank you um
questions represent
elme thank you on I'm trying to just ask
questions that you might know more about
uh from the commission than whatever
he's doing uh but the first one is are
there HRM contracts that would have to
be
broken uh are
there HHR sorry you call it something
else these days the horse racing
machines yeah the HHR machines yeah uh
well again there's a three year that's
why is this a three years 25 26 27 yes
three years uh this three years I'm not
sure what the length of these Agreements
are most of these most of the facilities
will will uh lease them that's good
question um maybe someone behind me
knows the answer to that but um I I I
would I would assume because this
technology evolves with these all these
different kind of machines and I I don't
this is my opinion you know you can
verify uh that I don't think they get
into long longterm leases of these uh
because they want to get the latest and
greatest machine in to do it so I think
they were giving these we're giving them
three years to get out of any leases or
I think leases would expire and probably
what would happen is when the lease
expires they're going to go to slot
machines yeah if I could another one
on who provides the
programming uh for the slot machines
when we were doing this for a long time
decade two ago on there was
substantial
um uh
testimony on and books that were written
uh that
showed that the programming for slot
machines is done from one central place
in a
casino uh and
changes as different clientele show up
in theot slot machine area on so that uh
they will get the maximum uh amount of
money out of the people who have come in
uh right can okay again I'm not an
expert in this but um
okay first
off in even in the historic racing Bill
and in this bill there is um there's a
range of of payouts in slot
machines uh and in historic racing
machines too uh the higher the lower the
payouts the less likely people are going
to come to use those machines because
they they they feel it they feel that
this this you know if you go to Vegas
there are all sorts of but if you go to
the old Vegas you get bigger payouts
there probably a lower overhead and they
they could they could tolerate that but
but if they if they set the if they set
the the payouts too
low so that they would make more money
they're going to lose business and now
in New
Hampshire as you know we we have agreed
to up to 19
facilities uh and there's going to be
competition that's going to prevent
uh any tampering with that that rate now
in terms of the machines themselves it's
in the bill I did see it again that U
all these machines and Charlie McIntyre
could testify that's better than I can
but all these machines are test they
have to be tested there's a there's a
lab that tests these things that that we
I don't know if I'm saying this
correctly but we contract with that make
sure that these machines aren't being
tampered with um and I I would I would I
would allow I I would ask Charlie that
understanding I did have a third if
nobody else's oh I've got several other
people with questions yeah but on
specifically and this is this is a dead
is uh complete utter dead end issue for
me uh is the problem gaming
money New Hampshire is a smaller State
than massachus it uh what seems like a
lot of money if it is not enough money
to reestablish the problem gaming uh
work in this state we are just depending
on addicts to run our state and I find
this extremely
offensive
so so my question is do you know
anything about uh does did the
commission look at how much money you
really need in order to have more than
the brochure that is mentioned in this
no we we didn't okay yes I actually M I
agree with you
100% when we and that's why as a
commission we had a little extra money
that was was allocated To Us by
legislation we had a second we had a
second consultant a chair a prom gaming
consultant come in so if you look at our
final report there's a there's a couple
of appendices one has the the spum
report and another there's a second
report had to do with problem gaming
again this wasn't our mission as a as a
I I took this where led us as a
commission and I said you know we got a
big problem we had people come in that
supposedly were doing something on on
problem gaming in the state but it was
very weak it was weak that's why we
engaged this other consultant they gave
us a lot of great ideas and again in our
final report we said that the
legislature should take up some of the
issues that are in this
report that we that we got from from the
consultant about problem gaming and we
we also agreed that we need a better
I I don't know without having the
numbers the current numbers what
this
0.0075% is okay it sounds small but it's
not going to
be I was just talking
to uh commissioner oh Charlie M
executive director of
Lottery about uh the the Nash opening
this
weekend and it was record setting
numbers astronomical numbers that would
if they kept
up just alone they would they would
would increase the amount of char if
this was in place how much money would
go to to problem gaming so uh we
couldn't conclude what the right number
was okay we knew it had to be more and
we left it up to the legislature to to
come up with that and again it's it's on
the thing for the follow-up commission
to deal with if the if the legislature
doesn't have time to do it the
commission should take this one up and
actually I said one of the first things
you should do is is take that up because
I wrote the report I said this should be
the one yeah so thank you yeah I I was
on that commission as well we did
discuss this we did recognize it a
problem and there is and thus you know
the recommendation that the legislature
take this up but the new commission will
also take this up uh if the if the
legislature is not acted um by the time
the commission has additional um
thoughts on how that should proceed
representative shamberg you have a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my I have two questions
so I'll ask for a followup when I come
uh concerning recommendation 20 about
undo concentration you mentioned the
Assistant Attorney General did he ever
use the words Monopoly and conspiracy
regarding
HHR he he is the one who came up with
the um Let me give me a second he's the
one who came up with the
uh the the point
that we should he said make it
consistent with
um where is it
make it consistent with uh article 83 of
the
Constitution what the words I read to
you were article 83 of the Constitution
so I guess yes he he that was from
him followup Mr chairman second question
by removing
HHR wouldn't
we uh be removing free and Fair
competition from the people to decide
which one they would like to do uh HHR
or this other one
slots
well all of us representing well you all
of you representing the people can make
that
decision I mean that's my best answer
well by people do you mean constituents
or do you mean the people running I just
say it says free and Fair competition of
Trades into in is inherent essential
right of the people okay so the that's
why I'm asking uh is this so but really
refers to is our
businesses that are we keeping is there
competition among a like business in
this case HHR manufacturers thank you
okay thank
you uh representative Southworth uh
thank you chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question I
wanted to just clarify number five of
the money uh going to uh Group B
retirement
I know there's a gap in the retirement
from the 2011 changes and so on that
they wanted to correct and various
sources have said there's going to be
money for that I think 40 million or
something I just wanted to clarify is
this to fill that Gap that we've been
talking about again the first time I saw
the spill was about four o'clock last
night yeah so um I I was hoping
representative the set was going to be
here to explain that I'm not quite sure
that was that I would assume I I I I
would say high probability is that's the
that's the reason okay thank you okay
representative M yeah thank you I have a
question on the uh license fees for HHR
this kind of goes back to legislative
intent which I hope you could comment on
it it struck me that the legislative
intent with the HHR was to have the mom
and pop class of Charities get some
additional money in and have that money
go to uh charities in
particular uh and what we found is that
with a very modest license fee for the
HHR
license uh it turned out that that
license could be in effect sold to a
third party operator through the
interpretation of the law that said
because the legislative intent was not
clear in the ATR legislation that under
case law uh the business could be
acquired along with the ATR license and
then had that property uh sold to a
major operator and relocated to another
part of the city
and as a consequence of that the HR
license became extremely valuable uh
from
$50 price that we charg to what I'm
estimate might be worth as much as $10
million so my question goes back to the
legislative intent was the legislative
intent on HHR to just have the mom and
pop uh operators use these machines
to um stay in place and get some
additional money or was it or was the
legislative intent to allow these opport
to sell this license and okay I'm gonna
give you my uh I'm gonna give you my
honest
answer and I obviously you know I was
involved with bringing HHR to New
Hampshire uh because I was supporting
the Charities the goal was to bring more
money to the charities in the
state and I and be honest with you I did
not recognize then what door that opened
up and it opened up a significant door
we only have I think one locally owned
facility left of the 19 licenses we now
have opened
up all of the major players are coming
in the door and they own these
facilities and uh I think and that's the
reason for the
commission because we we saw what was
was happening and we said wow but the
problem is that everybody's playing by
the rules that were in law and we didn't
change the rules the rules are the rules
low fees low whatever and and it's it's
happened okay we have what we have now
uh we have large facilities and we have
uh we have even the brook which is one
of the more profitable uh more
uh um places that people like to go
uh is doing well is going to expand Nash
opened up we're going to have the salon
place that's going to open it's going to
be very big so what the commission
talked about was that what's going to
happen is that the marketplace is
probably going to cleanse itself
eventually I mean a little bit happened
in in in uh in ashaa I mean there were
three facilities now we're down to two
one the two became
one uh
I don't know how long the other is going
to last there because these are these
have I agree I mean these for whatever
whatever reason these have become and
becoming real casinos with amenities
that people want and that's what Drew so
many people over the weekend to and you
you know to
Nashua because of the amenities the
restaurants the the entertainment all
that it's a it's a night out out people
view it as a night
out um and it it is just
evolved and that's why it was important
that you continue this commission to
address the issues and you've heard me
say this here that we need to modify the
model of how the Charities because if
you look at the example of the
Nash I mean it was I mean there were
Charities making
150,000 at the bigger places the Nash is
like gigantic and if we don't change the
10 days to something less or you know
each charity gets 10 days we have to
change that model and again that that's
it's also on the top of the list of
issues that need I tried to change it I
I gave suggestions of how to change
it uh and it needs to be dealt with and
I'm hoping that that's also one of
there's a lot of priorities here that
this commission should take up and
that's one of them because I I I would I
anticipated I showed my math to
everybody I said you
know a charity there could they can gain
up to $400,000 for 10 days that's not
right we want to we should sprend that
wealth to more Charities and U so I
guess the bottom line here is that the
good news is that we're growing we can
help Charities but but the legislature
has to act to change that allocation
model because we're not letting more
Char matter of fact we went we went from
three facilities in Nasha I told this
example last time one didn't have
HHR so there were three Charities that
were
helped now we have two
facilities and if they had to 10 days
each we only help in onethird less
because it's that Nash even though it's
gigantic it still has two two Charities
sponsored that night so we we need as a
legislature to jump on this and the and
hopefully the Senate will I don't know
where that bill is about forming the
commission I would I would strongly
matter of fact I'm trying to see Kelly
aot about this to strongly actually
believe it or not
um L delandro and I Senator delandro uh
different party than me um whatever
reason we got along and he and I been
talking he calls me periodically we talk
about what's going on on this and then I
said I'm trying to see Kelly about this
and he he he said can I come I go yeah
absolutely because he knows he knows as
well what we need to change um in this
in this model yeah that's all thank you
uh followup yeah just one follow first
thank you very much for your very
detailed explanation of the history the
only follow-up I have is regarding the
current license
fee on the ground do you feel that that
license fee is appropriate or should it
be changed to something more substantial
okay
you again Lottery could correct me if
I'm wrong but my understanding is that
there's 700 I think it's $700 a year to
have a game operator's license to have
the facility $700 a year whether it's
initial or renewal we talked about this
at length I was suggesting we increase
that through the commission but I
couldn't get the vote to do
it um my understanding is that
there was no additional fee and please
hope if I'm wrong U hopefully the
executive director corrects me uh we'll
have the director come up and answer
some of yeah please but my understanding
is that there's no additional fee for
the HHR
machines thank you representative Spar
thank you Mr chair is ggr is that after
payout right yeah gross Gaming revenue
okay is f payouts right okay follow up
follow up um the other question backing
to what representative shamber were
saying does I I don't know the law but
does it have to be either or as far as
uh slot or HHR or could you do both
that's I'm asking the same question you
are okay I I again I just read this last
night and I wish the prime sponsor was
here and that but my my interpretation
the way the way it's written in the
sections that come to effect I think my
interpretation is that it it it could be
phased in over three years so they can
have they can have both
because the new the new statute is the
beginning section one is the new statute
that has to do with the the uh slot
machines but the old statute the
sections don't get phased out until 2020
January
2028 so so to me both are in place okay
so a facility can phase out their
historic racing machines over time and
phase in machines is my interpretation
but I asked it as a question myself
because I think I think when I read the
legislation that's what it said okay and
if you look at the that's why it's
looked at it's important to look in
these in and if you're a new legislator
it's important to look at the
um at the uh well there's also in line
16 on page five
repeal you can see repeal what gets
repealed line 16 through 19
but repeal is not in section one it's
it's part of the rest of the
bill and the rest of Bill the existing
bill is
maintains historic racing until
2028 okay so so I interpret this as yes
the facilities can have both and they
can phase in and out at their speed that
they want to phase in and out of between
these two
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank you
all okay next I am going to ask Alicia
up thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee Alicia Preston I represent the
New Hampshire charitable gaming
operators Association we are here in
support of this bill as uh
representative abrami pointed out this
was a recommendation from a study
commission that took kind of a deep dive
into the industry and Spectrum gaming
who was the third party consultant that
they hired to look at the industry as a
whole uh we think this is kind of a
natural progression in the industry uh
we also support the 30% tax rate while
that is 5% higher than historic horse
racing as noted there is more of a cost
to run the HHR machines than there are
um video video video Lottery terminals
that's why everyone calls it slots video
Lottery terminals and so we think that
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you and next I'll invite director
um good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee Charlie McIntyre Lottery
director I owe you a pink
card out after I'm done yeah when you're
done it's fine I think I get drafted
regardless you know um obviously uh
these types of bills we don't take a a
fundamental position on and um as a
practical matter the fiscal note was
delayed slightly I think we got it to
you the day you printed the bill um but
I actually would would like an
opportunity to revise our Revenue
estimates um dramatically
upward um given the opening uh this past
weekend
and
um what's to come the facilities that'll
be opening soon um the revenue estimate
is based on a Statewide average which is
the way you would do it normally um but
that includes facilities which have
lower revenues there's two facilities in
Hampton which are based you know it's
not Hampton right now and there's a
facility in Belmont that's kind of
isolated as well um but the facilities
along the border which
derive I think the Nash's parking lots
in Massachusetts um significant
population density from the our Southern
neighbor um I have to revise upward
rather
significantly um moreover when we did
the fiscal note for HHR I believe our
digital Revenue estimates were $150 per
machine per day which was an accurate
representation based off of then states
that did HHR uh Kentucky Wyoming and I
think
Arkansas um based on our existing
revenues uh that is wildly
low wildly low um if you take out the
two Hampton facilities in Belmont the
average per room is
$287 per machine and growing rapidly um
that is the reason for example the brook
is expanding uh the rule of thumb in
gaming is if you're over $250 a machine
you add if you're below $250 a machine
you subtract and so I would imagine as
representative or former representative
Bry said I would imagine there'll be
facilities adding machines sooner rather
than later but I will happily answer I I
gather you folks have questions and I'll
happily answer anything that I'm able to
knowing this please this was not we
didn't write this bill we just commented
on it so that I ask you to if looking
for logic and why something says
something wasn't us that wrote it so um
I I have a initial question here looking
at the bill I have in front of me it
looks like there's no fiscal note um we
sent it over um like a few days late and
I have been working with um my question
yeah and certainly I and honestly it
would be outdated right now only because
of um the facility that open this
weekend and there's a facility opening
tonight uh in Rochester so it would be
old information and I'm indulge I apolog
oliz for not having it on time when do
you think we could have an
updated as soon as you what is give me a
date this week if you if it's that's
okay Tuesday Wednesday Thursday I could
update it um that would be great the
sooner probably the sooner the better
sure close business tomorrow you'll have
it thank you questions uh representative
opal thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you Mr director for taking my question I
I I'm just curious um and maybe I'm
thinking about this in the wrong way but
I would assume that an opening like the
Nash there's a novelty to it of sorts um
but historically what's been the
trajectory for these facilities is it
steadily up is it sort of Big Splash
initially and then it sort of levels off
or goes down what what's the what's the
history I mean it's a combination of
both population density is it given in
gaming the more Focus in an area the
obviously the higher the revenue um and
the Nash may represent what I would
characterize as a unique Place only
because I have some inside knowledge one
of my good friends was a senior vice
president of a very large gaming company
which I won't name because I don't want
to out him but when he did a review when
Hampshire was looking at casinos he said
the best location in the state was nsha
uh and then it was one of the best he'd
ever seen and so it might also just be
that nashwa has
it's not just nsha it's the southern
border if you put a pin in nsha north of
that circle is like 600,000 people below
that's almost two million and so you're
deriving a lot of people from
Massachusetts um to be sure opening
night's always a but I would tell you
that I was there when they opened and it
was supposed to be qu a soft opening and
within an hour the place was packed and
over the weekend there were lines for
machines which I would
I would guess that a lot of folks are
tired of driving to Boston the I I grew
up in quinsey uh outside Boston and
ever's not easy to get to and Foxwoods
is even less so and so I would imagine
that you're you're driving a lot of
traffic from the northern middle sex
Essex counties and so but once again the
information is only like four days old
so it's I'm at a you know dis Advantage
followup Mr follow up um but um again
yeah in the Hampshire whether it's
Southern Tier or Lebanon or elsewhere
what what has been the history of uh you
know and I I know obviously video
terminals slot machines are new or you
know not don't exist yet um but for
historic horse racing for these others I
mean do they do they tend to sort of
find a level and then they do they do
and certainly but that level opening
night is opening night so you don't
count that right and so so month over
month there's growth and we still have
growth the Spectrum report that was
referenced by representative abami I was
on that commission as well as
representative jigi and representative
jet um said the market for New Hampshire
is probably 6,000 machines give or take
if they were ideally placed across the
state for maximum efficiency that's
never going to happen the markets but um
that's what it looks like so we're still
well below that thank
you I'll try this again represenative
shamberg thank you Mr chairman thank you
director for taking this question uh on
page three line 10 it mentions 1/4 of 1%
of the amount collected payment will go
Services what is the present amount that
goes to these uh problem gaming services
and would this bill increase the
amount as I understanding currently the
amount is
$150,000 annually uh which is budgeted
it's budgeted from our revenues as a bud
budget item uh and this would that
percent would be more okay I haven't
done the back of the envelope math on it
yet but it would be more certainly as a
part of the fiscal note Mr chair if that
pleas the committee I can do that too as
part of the fiscal note as to what we
anticipate that number would be yeah it
we'd also like the historical uh amount
of money that was spent how much was
returned to the general fund or yeah
whatever okay followup Mr chairman
follow up sir thank you sir for taking
this question uh on line
14 uh d uh the remainder of the amount
collected to the Lottery Commission for
use according to the special fund
established under RSA 284 colon
2-j uh
your expenses come out first it for the
Lottery Commission in regards to this
and the the part of the question I'm
trying to get to is what percent goes
ETF doesn't 284 allows you to withdraw
first right sure it looks like it would
be um 60 um 60%
of the amount set aside for charities in
the state would go to the ETF
fund I say that if I'm representative so
if you take out it's so you get a dollar
SE on by the terms of this bill 70 cents
goes to the operator 30 cents goes to
Charities my question Mr Mr chairman is
of that 30% that goes
to you get to pull out your expenses
from that right no no so we don't
separately expense this
function so last year our net revenues
were $27 million our expenses were 15 so
for us to parse out what we spend on
Char little gambling versus what we
spend on lottery is just an act there's
no point our investigators do both
functions our Auditors do both functions
our
I do both functions so it's always just
charge the Lottery account for it that's
all if if I
might to follow up on
that that particular section talks about
door uh um dog and horse
racing and that's that's the title of it
but it actually refers to the funding of
the gaming
commission I'm sorry which section the
uh something 23j got to put my glasses
on here is 20 20j is the education trust
fund as I understand it 21j yes I don't
think
so I've I looked that up last night if
you want yeah yeah it first says that
the lottery expenses will be taken
out from the
special this special fund which is the
money that ends up at the Lottery
Commission and then the rest of it goes
to the education trust fund unless you
don't have enough to pay for your
retirement benefits which I think
probably never happens
right this P I don't think I can ever
retire I'm doing this from 15 years now
thank you
representative any other follow up on
that no here yeah that
thank Southworth starts with an thank
you for taking my question I asked you
in the hall the other day um you're ever
changing Revenue estimates those
basically takes to consideration one
machine being phased in and the other
being phased out so really the um
estimates are a combination of those two
things correct thank you and the and the
perceived growth for so the machine
we're not replacing machines the
machines are most of them are going to
stay it's just you're changing the
content in the machine itself like the
Box isn't going to change most of them
the communications is going to change
the surveillance isn't going to change
it's literally just the content inside
and the math behind it is what changes
and the content by providers there many
more of them that do that stuff so
representative
Elber thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um there are
three if there's time you mentioned that
uh saturation is about 6,000 machines
yeah give or take how many are there now
throughout the state as of well can I
say as of tonight at 5: um there'll be
3500 followup Mr
chair just going to go so there's
there's room for at this point about
2600 more based on that 6,000 C if they
were done completely strategically
perfectly I think yes um but that the
market will dictate that okay and these
operators are very good at knowing what
the market can dictate and not dictate
and address
accordingly followup Mr chair go ahead
thank
you at what
point do does saturation
actually happen I mean there's the
novelty of a new
casino we may be able to get 25 2600
more machines but is there a point at
which nobody else is interested or
nobody is interested in gambling more
than they do now it's a good question um
I and that varies by state and tolerance
and appetite of the consumer for example
the state of Oklahoma I think has 65
casinos um because they have Tribal
casinos and there are great number of
tribes in Oklahoma uh and whereas you
know Connecticut has
two it varies by state and by appetite
and you'll see the fewer in a
jurisdiction the larger they tend to
be one more thank you follow up
Nashville right now has three open
casinos the two big ones the lucky moves
is around the corner from my house
pretty much so I see all the cars there
um presumably that smaller Casino the
Moose will be
closing Gate City is still there yes
is what might be happening in terms of a
shift to people going to the Nash is it
what kind of impact is it likely or not
to have on Gate City it will have an
impact done Gate City no question um it
remains to be seen yet it's a nicer
facility just you objectively um there's
only so much money to go around in
discretionary income so have an impact I
don't know the exact answer because I
don't know what gate City's reaction
will be most of the time these folks
actually react and um they're likely to
move to another facility I've heard
stories about it I haven't seen
applications yet so till it's on my desk
I don't tend to hold it as gosp truth
yet but um I would imagine they'll move
to a nicer facility and build that out
to
compete thank you thank you Mr chair
representative Aly has a question two
two actually on the first one before I
forget it again on
is that
the the
um oh dear I have forgotten it so um
the O the other question that that I had
was the amount of oh I should write
these things down uh there there is a
section in here somewhere that says that
the
revenue
um
collected is
is going to
be um oh well there's the 30% issue
there are other bills out there that ask
for considerably more is that going to
be a
difference is it going to be a
difference significant yes
yeah so if we went up to the
50% that the governor wants the thing
the governor in hb2 is 45% 45 that's yes
and that's certainly at um after a lot
of research and effort into what is
essentially the marketplace in right now
for video Lottery terminals um 25% on
HHR is the lowest in this New England
for what the state gets as as a
take for a
machine
right um and
second the LA the I think this is the
same language we've had all along a
license shall not be transferred or sold
is there no way to write it to keep
large conglomerates from taking over
everything
um I would almost suggest that the
animals left the baring that one but um
that was that was the that was the
attempt of the bill yeah to your
question that was the attempt of the
bill but I will tell you this is that
the large operators have brought it in
professionalism that was candidly
lacking in some of the smaller mom and
pop shops uh and it hasn't been all
these are
very talented well vetted professionals
that are operating right now so
understanding the fear that out of state
has come in but they actually know what
they're
doing okay uh follow up and that yes
follow the last one is about the problem
gaming
amount yes um we have no problem gaming
help now apparently there may be a
brochure around somewhere that you can
hand to somebody if they actually decide
to come into the casino to say I've got
a
problem which seems like a weird place
to go if you have a problem and you know
it um but is there
any
um place in the country that is
sufficiently enough like with all of
these casinos all over the place that
are of significant size I don't think
the Indian ones are
um uh
that we we could get an idea of what
they're doing about problem gaming and
how much we ought to put in there
because if we put in there too little
we're never going to be able to get it
changed no I I agree with your OB to be
sure um and the ulty is in my job doing
both candid Lees being the director of
the lottery and also
running problem gambling I shouldn't be
both jobs it it would be a conflict
these people were perceiv a conflict I'm
fully in support of the measure and have
been forever it's just it's difficult to
do both jobs simultaneously and not look
like you're being disingenuous at one
but I should have turned that off sorry
um but do
we we we have no one else that's the
problem in New Hampshire and you tried
to recruit some people from
Massachusetts but it doesn't seem to
have worked uh not not so far correct um
not so far yeah and the budget in that
we have isn't sufficient to address the
issue because you need to have somebody
operationally stand it up train some
folks to do do this uh there are issues
of what I would characterize is
comorbidity a person who gambles is more
likely to smoke person who gambles is
more likely to drink um right and so
there's issues that that you could
address
globally
yeah but you think that the 3/4 of a
percent is enough prob I'd have to do
the math on it but I think I do believe
so based on what I know the the numbers
to be but I certainly as I suggested
I'll do the fiscal note um and I'll get
it to the chairman and committee members
by close business tomorrow I'll include
with that Ma what I think that math
looks
like okay thank you um
my my city already had a problem with
the small HRM machine place
on and our poverty agency being unable
to keep up with the number number of
people who became
addicted thank
you representative M yeah thank you
director McIntyre uh I appreciate the
work you're doing to uh oversee this
expanding operation my question relates
to your capacity to handle the
expansion I I had a long talk with Jeff
Lynn the president of Exacta saying that
um using these this model of a Off Track
Betting machine it's less burdensome on
the um operators and the regulatory
regulatory authority to maintain
Integrity in the games and if we went to
VTS that'd be much more of a burden on
our regulatory system here in New
Hampshire so my question is uh have you
thought about the capacity you need to
oversee uh 6,000 V Lottery Terminals and
uh can you at some point give us some
guidance on what budgeting we should
have for that operation I mean certainly
contained in the fiscal no which I get
to you on time um is a few extra
employees to add to my our staff to
review this um and some respects it's
harder some respects it's easier um
managing the pools regarding stor horse
racing the actual pools players play
against each other in it does take some
work so that would be less of a burden
and we've already gone through the
effort of placing a significant number
of the machines and their surveillance
everything is reviewed by us they can't
move a machine without telling us um has
most of that work's already been done um
we have another slew of initiatives in
the lottery that are draining our meager
resources uh we launched a new website
last week we're launching a new app
coming up we're changing out our gaming
system in the store
stores moving to a new platform on the
website and the our uh online platform
so it's not just the HDR side or the
gaming side that's been busy but I think
we're in good shape you know um but if I
would if I thought it was a problem I
would suggest to you I do have to that
point representes I do have a number of
open positions that I only fill if
needed and most of them are in chartable
gambling side so if we have a need
there's positions available and funded
uh we just don't fill them unless we
need them uh we don't we just don't
way represent Elber thank you Mr chair
one more quick question if I
may are there any Casino operators who
are hurting I I I assume this is a
pretty lucrative business but even in
lucrative businesses occasionally there
are outliers who are not doing well are
are any of ours here in that situation
the seasonal ones are um trying to find
their footing candidly uh Hampton Beach
is just not crowded in February you know
especially when it's negative five
degrees with a windshield of some um so
they're they're not
very profitable but um the rest are are
you representative opal let's we've got
other people one last quick question
just so I understand um thank you Mr
chair just and and thank you director um
just so I understand I believe I
understood you to say the switch from
historic horse racing to the video
terminals is a software issue not a
hardware issue correct it's a con it's a
Content issue and there's a cost
associated with it I'm not going to
downplay it it'll be you know three
$4,000 per machine but the machine you
would be very hard pressed to tell the
difference between one to the
other thank
you thank you seeing no other questions
thank you very much we're looking
forward to that note of by five o'clock
today
tomorrow thank you thank
you okay next up we or I guess the last
Horgan thank you very much thank you
much Mr chair I hope I checked off the
right box on my pink card I am in fact
in favor of the bills there's so few
bills that come around this year that I
like but this one and anyway I'm
resident Timothy Horan from straford
County District 10 the town of Durham
and we we don't have any historic horse
racing facilities in our town although
the next town over do does have a have a
casino and Al I hardly ever go there I
do have what of their what play like a
rebel cars or what is they hand out so
the I've just always felt like the
historic horse racing machines really
have nothing very much to do with horse
racing they use uh a database of old
horse race results as part of the random
izing function for the slot machine and
on the one hand that appeals to me cuz
my uh mother was from Kentucky she my
grandmother uh lived lived about a five
mile five minute drive from Churchill
down since she used to go over there so
much as I like horse racing or at least
at least part of me likes horse racing
um these machines really have nothing
particular to do with the horse racing
industry except they were sort of
invented as a means of uh keeping tracks
in uh Kentucky and other horse racing
States uh alive when people lost
interest in in horse racing but in any
case I don't think this is a good
randomizing uh this isn't a good
randomizing mechanism I think it it
creates another uh another vulnerability
for the computer systems that run the
slot machines it's uh one more thing
that a scammer either uh either an
internal one you know inside the vendors
or even with you know not art gaming
commission but maybe some other state St
gaming commission so it's one more it's
one more Target it's one more
vulnerability and it's um it's probably
more expensive than simply operating a
video Lottery tournament which is a pure
uses a more secure randomizing function
so I think from that that respect is
unnecessary the change will be virtually
invisible to the players the horse
racing side of the historic horse racing
things is hidden um if you do know the
right buttons to press you can see like
a little bit of the horse racing content
but you know it's really uh probably my
grandmother would probably be very bored
with it even though she liked to play
the horses because uh doesn't really
give you enough information to make an
intelligent guess about which horse is
going to win um so I would just say uh
the VTS there's some upfront cost but I
think that's a much simpler more
effective way I mean as for the larg of
issue whether we should have slot
machines here in New Hampshire and
whether the charitable gaming model is
the right way to go I have mixed
feelings about it but it does uh
some people do like it it does uh
generate some revenue for the stage and
for the Charities and uh it's one of the
few Revenue sources that like uh we
actually like having here in New
Hampshire so from that respect they're
fact of life so I would like them to be
simpler less and more secure so I think
to switch over to just a video Lottery
tournament from the so-called historic
horse racing is a positive step so that'
be happy to take any oh there is also
the issue of I will admit there is the
issue of velocity of play so I I only
heard the last witness and several other
people put in pink cards but that's uh
you know the feral Lottery termin can
operate at virtually infinite speed
whereas historic horse racing is kind of
slow but there are regulatory ways you
can do that even by simply you know
throttling the number of requests you
can make to the VT or there's probably
other Solutions so I would just say uh
so I support this bill and I apologize
if I checked off the wrong box in the
pink card so I'm happy to take any
questions but you checked off the right
box uh does anyone have any questions
um yes R and ORS thank you Mr chairman
and thank you representative Horgan did
you say you actually lived in Kentucky
no not me my uh my mother my mother's
from my mother's from Louisville so my
grandmother who's been dead since 1979
she lived near Church Hill down since
she used to like to go there
occasionally um she had she would get
the racing form she had a system it uh
she was pretty smart it worked well
enough for her to make make lunch she
didn't she never took me and my mother
along these outings that my mother
didn't really approve of it and uh even
for her I think the actual betting part
of it was kind of boring is more a
chance to just get out and have an
outing and uh usually get a free lunch
out of it so that was why she did it so
well thank you I used to live in
Kentucky or something about you oh we're
in Kentucky um given given excuse me
that's not a relevant question okay yeah
sorry given that we're about 45 minutes
behind schedule um we can talk about it
offline is there any other specific
question seeing thank you very
much okay uh that's all I have for pin
cards is there anyone else who'd like to
testify on HB
728 seeing none I'll close the public
728 that wasn't my
goal we're going to take about a f
minute break and we'll get started on
oh should just call me c
ready I don't mind driving The Rock
yeah to
rep I don't think so because it's under
50 because it's only our I mean unless
they give you gambling money when when
did they give you some
drinks oh well I would count in your
drinks I'll just get CH I was just
asking because I have to fill some go
they'll let you know right they'll let
you know we'll let you know Oh They'll
put something out there if you went to
the slock thing okay yeah I wouldn't
okay I just plan on have a couple olds
well that's it yeah I thought well I
wasn't going to go I got a club meeting
tonight what your Club a rifle club
meeting
yeah
e
737 that's right yeah so the last last
exec session on this um
was an it we had a motion of itl and it
had been seconded um but since then we
have a an amendment here and um and we
also have a better understanding of um
the bill I believe because we are that
itl motion was primarily put forth
because we were saying it was the same
as HB 247 which it is not um and so I
think at this point I think the first
step might be to unwind this and and
come back to um where we should be I
I representative ducett is not here to
take back his motion so I'm not sure how
um represent Al do you know how that
know I would think the situation uh uh
parliamentary wise would be that the
motion's been made the motion's been
seconded the primary maker cannot
withdraw but the secondary maker can
withdraw uh the seconder if he
withdraws second representative Murphy
representative Murphy you you had
seconded the bill so if you withdraw
your second
then okay I withdraw my second on uh HB
um 737 FN thank you okay okay there
therefore there is no second now there
being no second on that itl motion that
motion uh will not move
forward okay I have
um put so first let me let me say so uh
in taking a closer look at these bills
over the week weekend uh 247 while they
seemed very similar
um was a a bill that dealt with
HHR
um only and this bill while it seemed
the same U deals with charitable gaming
of which
HHR uh could be a component thereof uh
so so this is different this does uh
this should not be killed just because
it's quote the same because it isn't the
same um so anyways I have a an amendment
2025-the
the operator who ceases operation for so
basically if an operator ceases
operation
for a period exceeding two years then
the town could take a new vote on
whether to allow
uh gaming or not the amendment increases
the two years to four years uh and it
also
increases there was a period of five
years after a new application's been uh
approved that was five years this
increases it to 10 years the reasoning
Behind These increases are that there's
various uh situations that can happen
where an operator uh may need more
time uh to make to make sure that these
things happen and what it does it
prevents the town after voting a certain
way preventing the to giving the the
operator more time before the town can
come in and say oh we changed our mind
and as you can imagine there's a lot of
investment that goes into uh these these
things and so we want to make sure the
operators have enough time to
um to to follow up and and before a town
could take a vote reversing things
representative opal um thank you Mr
chairman uh
I first of all as I read the original
unless it's changed um it says ceasing
operations for a period of two years or
failing to commence operation within
four years not five as I'm reading okay
I may have misspoke on the on that I I
will just say that it it seems to
me um 31 if you've got an application
and you haven't moved on it in 10 years
that that seems like an exceedingly long
period of time to me and I just you know
I
I I I think I think as the original bill
says uh if you cease operations for two
years um
you're sort of sending a message but
certainly if you fail to move within
four years I think that's a reasonable
period of time I I'll just say I mean I
I understand the notion of your
Amendment and and maybe there's
some
some time in
between 4 and 10 but 10 seems like you
know what what are you doing for 10
years not moving on an application that
that just seems like you're putting the
community you a in a very very tough
situation that they can't do anything
for 10 years well let's keep in mind a
um when it's approved when the community
has approved it hopefully they've
they've done their due diligence on it
but these these operators depending on
the size of the facility they're
building and how many approvals they get
sometimes these things can take a lot of
time now whether tends the right or it
should be something else um the the
worst thing would be for an operator to
get caught up in the idea of four years
ran out they've invested you know
potentially millions of dollars town
bootes to reverse I first of all I guess
the question would be what are the odds
that a Town's going to reverse
themselves but if they did then we just
want to make sure that people have
enough time after making all this
investment not to be you know and and Mr
chairman I I understand that I mean you
know if if if if the town has given its
permission or or has not not acted I
mean if the town hasn't hasn't
affirmatively said
no um and and someone an investor comes
along and and begins that
process I I I understand there there
should be a time period that the town
can't then turn around and say y too
late but 10 years seems exceedingly long
to
me represent boards thank you Mr
chairman so uh I understand the comments
being made by my colleague here uh and
to me that would seem uh within reason
what he's saying however my experience
is different in that my son purchased
the ski
lodge and here in New England and it's
been five years just to get through the
permitting
process and so I would have thought that
4 and 10 would be crazy and unnecessary
but in today's world just getting a
permitting
process is it takes a lifetime and he
has invested well over a million doll
now and has had to file a lawsuit
against the state to recover some of his
funds due to their lack of uh due
diligence and negligence so I would
think the timing is just
fine okay I just um I'll take more more
in a moment but I just realized we we
need a motion to be this is an exact
session not a work session
um we Unwound the itl which is which is
fine I'm going to recognize
representative Yul for a
motion I move ought to pass and would
like to be recognized for an amendment
do I have a second second
by so we're talking about the initial
bill right now does somebody want to
okay Susan did you want to Second it
Murphy recognize
representative and I would offer
amendment to uh unapproved Amendment um
I got to learn how to use these damn
glasses
28418 yeah that
8418 and I'd like to speak okay and I'll
second well we need a second I'll second
that motion so he can speak
okay shamber seconds the that's nice
speak
um the time period on this seems to be
appropriate as uh representative ORS
previously commented sometimes things
can take a long time I know sitting on
the planning board in Hudson we've had a
couple of large developments in Hudson
and those things had been going on for
several
years just to get the money in place
just to get the Hampton notes available
and in the meantime the developers spent
literally in Hudson millions of
dollars it can be very
expensive uh regarding representative
opal's period also if you take a look at
your planning board situations most of
their uh time limits that they have have
an un limited number of
continuations that can take place so
rather than have the the town keep
coming up and no we no we'll defer no
we'll defer every year while they're
getting the monies in place set a time C
you got four years you got 10 years you
should ought to be able to put it
together by that time thank
you represent uh
elberger thank you Mr chair I wonder
if they're two separate pieces there's
the application approval and then the
permitting correct they're actually two
pieces and I wonder if adding changing
the time of the
application uh approval because I I
would
support uh the notion that that is too
long and maybe say something along the
lines
of um
however however many years following
application approval and a certain
number of years for the permitting
process which hopefully would put some
of the responsibility for potential
delays back on the
locality rather than saying well it's
it's the developers or The Operators
problem because they didn't take care of
it and saying to a locality if it has
been approved you have to get it done in
a certain amount of time which yes is
taking away some local
control but I wonder if it if there's a
pieces I don't know it yeah I don't know
I think I would keep it one piece but
this already is telling the locality
that you can't change your mind for 10
years on a new application uh because
there is I I think a lot of times we
just think okay locality approved it now
they can start you know the building
process but uh there there is a you know
representative or's Point uh and what
representative UL has seen on his board
a lot of times these guys spend years
just getting all the financing together
and so that's and then they then they
have to go through the permitting
process and then they have to build it I
think so it does seem like a really long
time but it's it's it's amazing how the
time does get get eaten up and and so
the the town B this bill is basically
giving towns the option to allow or not
allow well I don't know the def the
default
I think is what I think the default is
allow but a town can opt out of this um
and then they just can't uh change their
mind for 10 years yeah rivers and
open yeah I have a question on the
wording of the uh section Roman numeral
8 and whether that is consistent with
the intent that we
described uh the way I read Section 8 if
and be looking for a legal
interpretation of this that says that
the Min May prohibit
games but this shall not
apply to any games of chance licensed by
The Lottery
Commission so I read that as saying well
the town may not like the game if the
Lottery Commission has approved this
game the town doesn't have the right to
repr you what did you
I yeah I think missing on line 13 in
between the word
um uh operator and licensed is would be
the word
currently or any applicant who has
applied because that would make the the
first half of that phrase or that
sentence phrase the
phrase uh comply comport with the second
half which is an application
in existence as a and this would then
say current operator currently licensed
prior to this so that somebody was
already in operation you couldn't have a
vote to get rid of them and take them
out well I think yeah I see what you're
saying but I think if an operator is
licensed they're they're currently
licensed um so I think I think uh I did
that would also be the the other way I'm
just just trying to follow up on what
represen will say okay does that make
sense represent so basically what it's
saying is if you're already operating
they the town can't decide you no longer
can operate or if you if you are in the
queue
basically the applicant's been approved
follow up on that the the past tense and
licensed which exists a license in place
yeah yeah I I guess I'd feel better with
a interpretation of this a legal
interpretation and the realize the basis
for my question is what's happened with
historic horse racing when we had a
Prohibition that the license cannot be
transferred or sold and indeed there was
a legal wrangling over that where the
license was transferred or sold by the
sale of the business so I'm very
sensitive to the specifics of the
wording in here and I want to make sure
that there's no
preemption by the city and towns
correction there's no preemption by the
lottery that the city and town must take
this game even though the town did not
want
it and the way I read this language is
that if this is a game that's approved
by the lottery the town must take it
doesn't have the option to opt
out well that yeah that would make sense
they're already operating Mr chairman
yes represent elberger thank you
I if some if a an operator is licensed
by The Lottery Commission and is
operating in another community that
person is still licensed
correct the license isn't limited to it
is all right so that limited to the
community to that Community yes all
right I I'm finding that
this this wording is confusing enough to
enough of us I think that I think it
might make sense to defer voting on this
up represent op um I I will just say
again
um this is unlikely to
happen but under this
provision I could file a
license uh in every community in the
state and preclude every community in
the state from having the opportunity to
vote on whether they want a casino or
not um because this says if if you if
you filed a license and then you have 10
years to act on that license um which if
you if you don't have at least some
beginning I understand there are delays
and and maybe four years isn't long
enough but it seems to me we are hand
capping a town or a municipality for 10
years um if you haven't gotten your
financing together if you haven't gotten
your plans together if you can't
commence
operations
and you know um
maybe I could even see changing the
commence operations to perhaps to some
other to some other Milestone but I I
just I have a real problem I can't I
can't support 10 years and and allowing
a a community be tied up for for a
decade that just seems
um too long to me
represent take a look at the
process no one is going to give be any
financing if you don't have the
permission of the town so the very first
step is to get the permission of the
Town once that has taken place all of
the other stuff can take
place let's say you're going to build a
facility like the Nash it took them I
would I'm saying around five years to
get that redo the Sears and modify it
I'm I'm sure uh commissioner McIntyre
could give us the exact number of years
and days involved but it took a period
of time it also takes a period of time
to make sure that the financing there um
there's not some special bank that
gives away money for these things well I
probably is but uh yeah there is it
still takes just going through the
permitting process uh of your planning
board it's going to take a good 18
months for a large facility to get
redone because they're going to be well
I don't like that traffic study let's do
another traffic
study well if I may Mr chairman I I
serve on the planning board in my town
so I'm familiar with the process and and
um you know um I would say in each of
the cases we've heard you know might
take 18 months to do this and you you
know you're' going to have to get the
permission of the community to get
financing um one of the things that I
heard on the last bill from the director
was that
apparently and this may be a good thing
um or not I guess we'll find out over
time but it is clear that the folks who
are coming in to do business are not Mom
and Pop operators who who don't
understand the process of of building
these things of getting the permits of
getting the approvals um
they're they're big players in the in
the gaming industry um they know what
they're doing they know how to do this
and I can't imagine that they want to
tie their people up for 10 years um
unless there is something else going on
and so I you know I understand again I
will say again I understand that this
isn't going to happen overnight um and
perhaps four years to commence
operations is not
sufficient but going from four years to
10 years particularly given the nature
of the business and the players who are
who are coming into the state of New
Hampshire I I I think to to tie the
hands of a community for 10 years is is
just
inherently um
extravagant represent
elberger thank you Mr chair I just did a
a quick Google search the Sears in
nashwa which is the space that is now
occupied by the Nash closed permanently
in February of 2020 so in just over 5
years they took care of
everything and that's an enormous
facility so I would tend to
support the notion that 10 years is way
too
long represent om did you have a your
light is on yeah I was hoping to ask
director McIntyre if he could weigh in
sure it's it's okay I can give you
invited uh certainly the Nash is the
largest facility we have in the state um
but the individuals who own that had
tremendous resources to bring to bear to
sort of make it happen um the longest
project I ever saw that lingered would
have been the Rockingham Park project
which I think was probably a decade uh
in terms of getting that that approved
but the process goes you go to the town
first and you come to us last you have
to get Town approval first before you
come to us and then we have our approval
process um but it's usually done un lock
step not we don't wait to help you
before you you apply with us but we you
last approval like today the Rochester
facility is getting its approval today
but it's it's final approval the whole
process our folks work with you on on
your internal controls your surveillance
plan your cash path all those things so
um the Nash was a special example
because it is so large um but it's I
think Conway might have been five
years uh the facility in Conway because
they went through a couple of towns
approval rejection lawsuit hearing it I
think that was five could be wrong but
it was a long process what what did you
say took 10
years I mean certainly if it can jam up
so this is game's a chance so this is
just real sort of card games um table
games
um it would be odd to sort
of you know file an application every
city or town because there's 220 and
most of them don't have enough people to
actually support a gaming chance uh and
the facilities that are open now are
really the ones you would have ideally
because they have both table games and
machine worked together well um I I
don't have an opinion on it it would be
a decision by you well what what I was
asking is you when you first sat down
you said I thought you said something
took 10 years to get approved uh the
rock Rockingham Park which did not get
approved the casino rockan Park that
process
lasted um the Millennium folks when
there was the casino bill under Governor
Hassen yeah uh they had worked on that
project probably for oh probably 10
years um through from 20
so I'm just saying that's the longest I
know of there project that didn't get
approved and they spent Millions so 10
years isn't out of the question it's
unusual but it's not out of the question
correct correct now obviously they were
having to change then standing state law
so obviously that takes a whole other
process to get through this legislature
but Mr chairman yes sir that that
project um was
not a a proposal under existing state
law LA and it was just a question of
getting the permits from the town and
then getting the approval from the
Lottery Commission it involved an effort
to change state law to permit a casino
to exist within the bounds of the State
of New Hampshire so I'm not sure that
that's uh an appropriate e example um
and I I guess I would ask the director
if there any other examples he cited two
now that both took five years um are
there any other examp you can think of
five thank you represent BS thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to ask you a question
if I could please uh why did the
Rockingham Park uh project fail uh it
was a vote of legislature and the vote
was negative okay okay thank you follow
not not a followup but just comment you
know I'm hearing a lot of discussion
over here about I think this and I think
that but like I've already said
experience tells me that 5 to 10 years
is within R uh within reasonable means
we've already heard couple these
projects took five years so four to 10 I
mean somewhere between 4 and 10 is five
and my son's been at it for five years
and he hasn't even Broken Ground done
anything yet other than get through the
permitting process and like I said the
only reason he got through the
permitting process was due to go to
court and filing a lawsuit he won the
lawsuit and then the judge had to go
back and go after the town and put the
town on notice that they're going to
issue the permit otherwise he'd still be
waiting so four to 10 years very
reasonable representative
Brier kind of listening to this
discussion and uh I was uh the selectman
rep to the planning board in the town of
Northwood I was kind of involved with
town of Northwood for 21 years and I'm
kind of looking at this and uh what is a
reasonable it sounds like FES too little
T like I was thinking why don't we just
work as opposed to you know just I don't
have a problem the 10 years but if you
have to get everybody on board if it's
like seven or eight years would that
work well I guess we'll ask that
questiones I was going to say Mr
chairman U um responding to my colleague
um representative ORS I think the
testimony we've heard here um about EX
examples specific examples has
been um I the director said he couldn't
think of any other than Rockingham that
was more than five years um so you know
um that's based on not opinion that's
based on you know what what his
experience is I I would say this Mr Mr
chairman is it appropriate for me to
offer an amendment to the amendment that
would change the 10 years to six years
sure it's
appropriate how do other uh so are you
saying that if this said six instead of
10 you would you would be OTP on this I
if we could change the 10 to six I I
would be far more comfortable with that
yes sir yes I I would I would vote OTP
otpa all right um I don't know between
represent Aly and represent Southworth
who had your light on first so I've had
my light on for a long time okay we'll
go with representative Aly yes this is
fundamental to this
bill um it talks
about games of
chance that means that we are
considering as
identical on the effects of poker
games and maybe a little Roulette in in
a place on
and and
HRM and H
H HHR you call it nowadays uh
and uh V VT machines they're total those
last two are in a totally different
category they were banned and they still
are banned in our in our legislative
language um
back on back many decades ago and it's
still in the language even though PE
it's old language so the new stuff can
just just say never mind that we've
changed it but you haven't changed it
there but they are very different things
they are the reason that a lot of us
spent a lot of time for about 12 15
years fighting against
the casinos and won every single vote
until after we went
into uh after the pandemic
ended but
um what worries me is that if we're
treating them the
same then any place that has been
licensed for poker which is something
that a lot of people like to play and it
used to be played in the back rooms of
their ho houses uh every weekend uh but
we finally legalized it and and it is
part of the games of chance now uh every
single one of those could be turned
without a vote into a major
casino and there are a lot of them
around the state I don't know how many
casinos aren't uh poker rooms considered
games of
chance game of skill yeah no it is game
same and and the poker that we legalized
those our ours opened as a poker
room and everybody was
delighted and then all of a sudden it
had been turned into a
casino but this this bill doesn't
address that I mean the the concern that
you have isn't going to be addressed by
this bill this bill is giving localities
a local option to to stop to if if they
aren't already a game of chance place
and my understanding was that games of
rooms but if we don't you say there's
okay so HP 247 is allowing
HHR yes this is games of chance right
and you're and um director McIntyre is
are in the title of games of chance does
okay because that was that's something
that we and video Lottery terminals are
where so this wouldn't automatically
include
loopholes so is there anything in this
language
that
we were hit by a Lo loophole in our
opinion but and represent you're you're
you're worrying about the loophole being
that this would allow for more than what
you considered games of chance also you
worried it could
include uh well can't include HHR
because you said that that has its own
section actually VTS now would it's not
approved yet VT has own section to
that's what what we'll be looking at in
hb2 this
afternoon um yeah well the the way the
governor did it
yes but that would mean people would
have to wouldn't they have to be
yeah representative South Southworth
thanks back to the numbers uh issue um I
know there have been a v variety of
comments and maybe another amendment but
for this amendment that we have in front
of us would it be worth it to just do a
straw poll how many people are willing
to go along with the 10 years so then
you'll know where we're
at sure and then if that doesn't do well
you could say eight years or something
moving okay can I just ask one
clarifying question regarding
representative opal um so if I'm
understanding what representative Aly
was getting to it is a concern that
someone could
file an application to have a poker room
and that would preclude the community
from voting to prevent that right and
then that that um entity would then use
that to get a license
or um that that somehow the the town's
inability to opt
out would would essentially preclude its
ability to opt out of historic horse
racing or the video terminals well let
represent El me answer that yeah I mean
I'm just trying to understand if that's
the concern and and if the director
could say whether that's
feasible at least in my community it was
considered a poker room it had some
roulette um I think it may have
occasionally had
craps and but and all and both of those
didn't we end up with 28 is the end date
moratorium that sounds familiar but
so
yeah 20
2031 okay seven years
okay uh representative elberger I guess
I'm getting even more confused the more
this conversation goes on if someone
applies for a
license and is approved for a license
does that license cover
everything or is a license limited
to poker in small table games or is it
once you get it you can do anything you
want the director will answer that
question took an opportunity the answer
is no you would be eligible just for
games of chance which are table games
which are the candidly the least
profitable of the games we that the
lottery licenses so it's unlikely that
you would have many of those crop
up but is it completely
prohibited that you could apply for
games trans license no it's not it's
just you wouldn't be eligible under the
existing law for historic horse racing
machines or the proposed video letter
terminal um
bills thank
you representative Aly but
what would stop someone from getting one
of those
licenses and
then saying that this would allow them
to get to that they are eligible for I
don't understand this eligible for
language that they are eligible to get a
license for or VT or or historic horse
racing in the HHR language there is a
date of Eligibility you need to be in
good standing as of a certain date
having applied by a certain date and
they wouldn't have been done that they
wouldn't have finished that or wouldn't
have completed that
process
correct obviously that any moratorium is
obviously subject to a future voted
legislature so it's 31 in law currently
you had mentioned earlier that you work
with PE people to get their licensing
which is that's the way government's
supposed to
work and uh however you don't issue the
license if the law says that the the
community has to approve it uh for
example Kino where the community has to
you're not issuing the license to
operate that Keno machine until the
community passes the uh or approves it
correct we wouldn't accept an
application if that was the case so
there would and under this law as
proposed the same situation would exist
is that correct
correct so the bit about applying for a
license and getting a license and then
cutting the town out is a nonse no they
go to the town first representative to
to your question they Town go you go to
the town first then you come to after
the fact thank you I guess as a
follow-up to that though this bill 737
is an opt out bill so with what you just
said does that still apply does the town
still have to they would have to the
town has to approve whatever they do
obviously because the parking roads curb
Cuts whatever but if they're opt the
town votes stopped out like for example
Salem um Salem voted to have gaming only
in certain areas we respect that vote of
the Salem of the town of Salem and if
you send us the license application
that's not in that area it's rejected
okay so so the town
still so I guess there's two levels of
town here one level is the the boards in
the town uh what you're saying is they
you're not going to issue a license till
the boards say okay the the other opt
out or opt in depending on which one it
is the town's people voting on that
correct okay so there's still so I guess
to to answer that concern there there's
still if if a town does not want it they
still at the board level can prevent it
even if it's an opt out so this is an
opt out where the town would have to opt
out but it's not like I think represent
Opel was concerned that they'll just put
an application in and now the town is
stuck that's not the case based on what
director McIntyre is saying okay but
this is totally SE opposite of the
experience that we had because there is
a another board that was created fairly
recently that uh is quasi judicial and
boards and we had hanging over us on a
one a requirement from that place that
was saying that on you have to decide
all of this within a reasonable amount
of time and you have to have what we
consider good reasons to do it
and maybe it was because we had a
planning board member who was pretty new
and who
spoke uh contemptuously I think it was
of the applicant uh that we ended up
with this dictum but we did end up with
this
stim
me representa y followed by represent
opal yeah yes representative Aly that
exists within a 60-day time limit within
the planning board regulations it's not
a separate board it's a it's a a
function of law uh once the application
is accepted and read in and public
hearing is head a decision has to be
made within 60 days uh my understanding
of the reasoning for that was because
there were certain communities that were
well we use the term dilatory on the
floor and then being polite to what was
happening in some
places this was actually a board that
was put in because I heard about it
first when he was talking about how uh
they had stopped Lebanon from continuing
to ask for a real
traffic
report still would have been within
represent
op um well I will I will say that as a
planning board member if you speak ill
of an applicant before you've made a
decision you've you pretty much put
yourself in a position of being sued and
and probably rightfully so but I I yeah
exactly um but I W I will say I was
under
the misperception I guess um that this
would have affected um HHR and and and
potentially video
terminals um taking those out of the
equation the only example that's gone
past 5 years was Rockingham Park and a
casino um which again I would say uh if
you're talking about opening a poker
parlor or you know a small game of
chance operation which is more likely
than you're going to open some huge
facility with 25 or 30 or 50 poker
tables
um we're not talking about a huge amount
of investment we're not talking about a
casino we're not talking about you know
those kinds of activities and so I would
say even
more um you know that that says to me 10
years is just way way out of for for for
this for what we're talking about 10
years seems just excessive
uh yes represent Malloy Mr chair uh
uh representative Southworth uh
recommended a straw pole are we pass
that or are we moving into
other areas here to I you know it's
interesting I was just about to okay say
that because it sounds like because of
new understanding of this bill it sounds
to me like the main impediment is the
10year um but I want doing a straw poll
so um if we if we amended this amendment
to um so so there's two pieces here one
is the two years of non-operation going
to four years and then there's the other
part of four years of a new after new
application to 10 years so is is
everyone first of all so there's two
parts so the first part is everyone okay
with the two years going to four years
hand okay so you one two 3 four five
6 7 8 9 10 11 okay so we have enough
people to go along with that the other
part is the four years going to 10 years
um I think we've heard a lot that 10
years is too long how many of you are
good with eight
years one two three four five six
seven8 it's not good enough because we
believe six years and you didn't ask for
10 of might be
10 well I I don't think 10's going to go
anywhere because eight eight just didn't
didn't do it how many would be okay with
six
years one two three four five six seven
eight 11 12
13 how many how many would be good with
seven
years well you're good with
anything all right so it looks like six
years is is where so so so then let me
ask one last question then if we have an
amendment the only change to the
amendment that I've put forth would be
that the 10 years goes to six years
that's the only change who's going to
vote for the ought to
pass one two three four five six seven8
nine 10 11 okay so we have enough to do
that so why don't we uh maybe what I
should do is uh recess this um we're
going to be back here talking talking
about uh
hb2 and um and at some point when we get
this amendment back we could uh vote on
that so um represent
Aly yes I still do not understand the
relationship between this and being able
to get a
casino if this is got nothing to do with
a
casino uh by Casino you mean what I mean
either the historic horse racing
machines or the
VTS well uh according to director
McIntyre those are under separate areas
they are under separate licenses but
they somehow are tied together that you
have to have this to have that or been
get exis La under existing law yeah
because the more more T than we pass
yeah but then if we pass
VTS then
then they would still need to pass they
would still need to have to acquire a
new set of
licenses and go through the entire
process for all that other stuff so you
couldn't take a a a poker room and
convert it into a casino without going
through the process of
taking your poker room and converting it
into a casino which would be a
separating separate process from
scratch from scratch except for this
eligible
for
as
universe it just all that said to me all
that says is you pass this background
check now you can go ahead and apply for
the
licenses you're eligible for because
you've done onethird of the process now
complete all
right but that only applies to the
I think it's included in the BLT license
it is what it also suggests I would
think is that when we you know with the
with the
VT we should have an amendment that
permits towns to opt out like
this yeah that that's certainly possible
and that would be separate from this
yeah okay would this make it eligible
no no this doesn't make VTS eligible
right no you still have to okay so um
then I'll call Ol see if I can get them
to update that one number there's one
more thing about it why did you add in
there Roman two because it's the same
the
I don't know if it's the same it doesn't
guess I just want to tell them the the
less we tell them to change right now
the more chance we'll have this done so
if it's the same we're fine okay all
right so um I'm going to recess the exec
session until um uh Mr chairman before
you do that do you want me to withdraw
my motion of otpa on this amendment yes
I will thank you so otpa has been
withdrawn uh the OTP motion still is on
the floor and we're going to try to get
a different Amendment I'll recess this
until
uh let's say 1 pm I know it's going to
be later than that but I'll recess this
till 1M so that uh we do start we'll be
within the time frame sometime I guess I
could recess it to 1:30 yeah okay uh the
executive session uh what we will do is
let's can we get back here at uh
1:15 to start working on hp2 until we
get that
um so okay so we we will come back at
1:15 I've recessed the exec session
there
e
saying
um the time being 1 128 uh we're going
to U hear a few words from uh
representative om on his handout here
regarding um
hp2 well what and regarding gaming he
has to leave in two minutes so U go
ahead thank you Mr chairman so what I've
done here is a summary of what the
current law says for the split between
the
operators and the state among these
various
bills so the first part of this page
this handout is the current law which
split 75% to the operator 25% to New
Hampshire and of that total amount of
money here's the splits detailed out
between the lator operator Lottery and
charity
the bill we heard this morning of
Hospital 728 is a 7030 split 70 to the
operator 30 to the house house being New
Hampshire so under this split the
lottery gets 18% the lottery to be
distributed to um the uh education trust
fund and related uh authorizations the
charity gets 10 a half% group two
retirement a new uh beneficiary gets 1
425 and problem gaming is Susan alahad
asked about gets
0.075 of the
money then if you look at to hb2 what
the governor's proposed the governor
proposes a 55 45% split 55 to the
operator 45 to New Hampshire to be split
in these defined ways roughly a third a
third a third between charity the
education trust fund and group to
retirement and then I will not step on
Senator Lang's toes because he'll he'll
describe Senator Bill 83 but on my read
of the current version of of cability 3
the operator it's it's a 60 40% between
the operator and New Hampshire we're
under Senator Lang Bill the operator
gets 26% Charities get 14 group two
retirement gets 13 and the other half is
split 50/50 to Lottery and to disabled
folks who need some assistance with
their property taxes so this is just a a
high level summary and I hope you keep
that in mind we look at the bills and
decide what is the right split of
revenue between the operator and revenue
to New Hampshire thank you Mr chairman
thank
you
um all right I'm I'm going to recess
this work session until after we finish
uh our exec um I'm going to reopen the
737 and I have I have the updated
Amendment the only change being I should
have passed this out the only change
being
years I'm did I say it backwards uh
years the motion on the floor is ought
to
pass uh for HB
737 um and representative ulery would
you like to make a motion for this new
is
08 okay do I have a second on that
Amendment I'll I'll second the amendment
for discussion okay represent look what
happened to the last I know represent
it okay would you like to speak to your
amendment 10 years is now six
years okay I guess we did have a lot of
discussion before
um are there does anyone have any
concerns um about this bill and its this
amendment now in its present form
represent
elme she raised her
hand bring that back again uh yeah go
ahead
um where is this
that I can't remember we were discussing
this at lunch I can't remember
what beyond that went on and I don't
think this has anything to say about
how
um non about transferability or
non-transferability
guess I don't have a remark except for
anyway anybody else
um is everybody okay with this uh
wording any
concerns okay all right then uh yes
represent
southw thank you um
iops I think after a long discussion
it's a good compromise thank
you okay I'm going to ask the clerk to
call the RO on the amendment thank you
2025-the
I representative ducett is not present
clerk votes yes representative soti yes
representative
ORS not
present representative Smith is not
present representative Tierney yes
representative Brier yes representative
Ford not present representative Murphy
Aly I guess yes I'm still not sure how
this applies to
everything thank you representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative Jeffrey
Smith not present representative Opel I
representative Spar yes chairman
janigian
yes with u four members absent chair
counts 15
to5 do we have it feels like we have
more than four people absent five
members we've got one there were five
no two three four five oh he might be
had five no how many people are here 1
two three four five six seven8 nine
10 15 15 okay then
there's 15 Z five absent okay
15 the vote being 15 to
zero um should this go on consent let's
see it could go on consent it doesn't
have a fiscal note is there any
objection to
consent oh I'm sorry yeah good well I
wouldn't expect objections yet then okay
great okay so the amendment passes 15 to
zero um now we will is there any more
discussion on the bill as amended if not
I will ask the clerk yes represent Aly
i' just like to make clear to everybody
this put your microphone oh clear to
everybody this is talking about a
totally different
issue if what we've been told is right
um
from the
two uh
247 ought to pass from Municipal and
County which is talking about uh horse
racing machines
right
right thank you it's a different
universe and nobody has yet done
anything about
about the
VLT correct thank
you represent shamberg uh thank you Mr
chairman I I just have a question if the
director can answer this Lottery
director if he can listen from way back
there and hear my question to you Mr
chairman uh is games of chance license
was it the underlying requirement for
all Casino operations this bill will
McIntyre
okay okay seeing no more questions
comments thoughts I will ask the clerk
to call the role do we have a motion of
vot
TPA yes the motion is otpa
by uh the motion well it's the O who
made the
OTP had a motion to adopt the amendment
now we have to vote on adopt the bill as
amended right so and this goes away now
this
so we have the a now we have the the
moot the motion is
otpa as amended by um
20258 on HB
737 that motion no yeah uh motion no
it's we oh we have to okay we need need
to make
representative I move ought to pass as
amended as amended thank you today
second
by okay seconded
shamberg
yeah all right clerk will call the role
thank you Mr chairman we are voting on
ought to pass as amended House Bill 753
as amended by 737 corre HB
737 the record shows HB
says yes representative dued is not
present clerk fa yes representative sodi
yes representative ORS yeah I knew that
not
present stepen Smith is not present
representative Tierney yes represent
Brier yes representative Mary
Ford not present representative Mary
Murphy yes representative Aly yes
representative Southworth yes represent
pres Malloy yes representative shamberg
yes representative Bolton yes represent
elberger yes represent Jeffrey Smith not
present represent Opel I represent Spar
here he had his invisibility cloak on
but he took it off votes yes and
chairman janigian votes yes V yes I
count 1 2 3 4 5 absence I count 15 Z
with five
absent the vote being 15 to zero um we
will put this on consent unless uh
representative ulery or Aly has a
descent to that no it'll go on consent
unless okay it's on consent seeing no
objection okay close the exec session on
hb7
37 you're supposed to hit the pad
yeah all right now we can get back to uh
HB 2 so
I'll reconvene the work session on HB
2 or the I should say the relevant
okay
organized
so all right I guess was lamb yeah so
it's public okay for those of you who
may not have seen the uh public public
notice yet uh representative ducet has
resigned and he is taking a job um with
FEMA as a I think it was division
director
um I may not have that warning exactly
right but the point is uh we will not
have him in the committee um and for
those of you wondering why he wasn't
introducing his bill this morning that
was
why okay are used saying you can't
introduce a build when you're not a
member all right so let's get let's get
to work on HB on
hb2 you have a fiscal note quick
guide uh is this from Dr yeah
Dr and
uh you should also have the handout of
uh the title being
hb2 as introduced page 39 is at the top
of the the
handout um I think this document was was
roughly I don't know 70 or 80 pages long
but this is the 98 the page 98 pages but
Means let's see trying to find I looked
at it this weekend I have some notes
here so I guess we'll just go make sense
to go in order
39 one of the main the main components
here is we had talked about uh VTS video
Lottery terminals a little bit in our
exing of
737 and uh here here is introduced in
hb2 the whole idea of of ushering in a
uh New Era of uh Lottery machines so I
guess let's let's kind of take
this um not necessarily Page by page but
maybe section by section so section 65
66 and 68
um and I guess
68 and 69 yeah 65 65 through 69 deal
with BLTs so the top of
39 you can is what we were
asking yeah you can ignore the the top
of page it doesn't affect Revenue right
we start with 65 so we're starting
that's on line 20 so on the first page
you're looking at starting at line 20
and then going to the next page to uh
line 16 that that's what we'll discuss
first and that all deals with VTS video
Lottery terminals and recognize
representative
YY uh just a linguistic type thing I I'm
trying to figure out how in
law or in the budget the governor has
any input other than suggest and then
the finding section which I think it
just that's just minor but the general
court finds I don't care what the
governor
finds unless she finds a lot of gold
some place that she's going to
share well I think I think what's
happening with this this
isn't this isn't ready for prime time
this is just like a starting document uh
the um no no I realize that U Mr chair
I'm just saying that should crossed out
spitballing yeah yeah yeah
okay represent elme yes
um I think uh this is the governor's
bill
it corre is yes uh expected to be
redrafted by Finance before it's
finished right um I would just like to
put down a
marker that uh Finance should be
deciding where the funding would go yeah
after it figures out what what else in
the budget has to be funded and can't be
funded by the revenues
right yeah it's a good point we we don't
need to figure out
all all the funding or any of the
funding issues per se where ways and
means we're interested in what revenue
is coming into the state represent
opal um Mr chairman my understanding is
that our role essentially is to make
recommendations to the finance committee
that that they'll ultimately correct opt
a budget to present to the Full House
yeah um one of the things that I think
we should very strongly
recommend is to adopt and I apologize
for not having prepared this in advance
but adopt similar
language um for an opt out or opt-in
provision the language could be borrowed
I think from 737 which we just adopted
mhm but I think they're absolutely if
we're adopting a new form of Gaming
I think um we should give the
communities uh the
opportunity to vote um on whether their
own constituents their own
citizens okay um would would concur
right okay yeah and and whatever we
decide here is you know it's it's not
binding obviously we could we could give
them all sorts of input we could just
you know um
I could close the meeting now and we
could go home and they'll still they
they'll do whatever they're going to do
however if we have strong
recommendations we hope that uh they'll
take them into account uh uh
representative elberger oh I'm sorry I
keep missing representative Southworth
let me go to representative Southworth
okay thank you he's been very patient
just for 65 as we've heard this morning
um these revenues are going to vary
tremendously we have a snapshot right
now but we really don't have a good
indication especially over a couple
years what these revenues are going to
be so we're really just um validating
that they're going to be used but we
much um I mean based that's true we
don't have an exact number based on what
Lottery has said yeah you know that we
really don't have over time unless you
yeah he's always got a Crystal bomb he
just doesn't tell us what's exactly in
it um I have an idea just based on Old
information it's more than what I
anticipated so generally this committee
likes that yeah
yes U so that's that's the only
hesitancy I have on numbers is that it's
I was I was really surprised at how big
the Nash opening was so follow up well
specifically I mean NASA doesn't have
VTS obviously so specifically VTS
um you know we we won't know that
obviously right right and the followup
would be um because the numbers aren't
here um that were in the governor's uh
Revenue but you're saying you expect
them to be much higher yes thank you
that's I just needed that cleared up
thanks thank you repres you may want to
stay there for a few minutes if you
don't mind uh representative um elberger
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking yet
more questions um I know you cannot tell
us how much money might come in as
additional funding from
gambling the uh estimate from
Dr is that with the cuts to some other
taxes
the education trust fund would be losing
about $95 million because of cuts in
business taxes and other are you
anticipating as much as potentially 9 $5
million coming out of gambling from the
new VT machines that would be going in
to replace it yes that much yes the um
so we're not changing machines like I
suggested earlier this is just a machine
that's migrating content right um but
because it's HHR now goes to education
trust fund and now VTS will be split two
ways half education trust fund half
under the hb2 half to the group two
retirement system that number may you
have to replace that funds because HR is
being taken out entirely so that's why
half of it's going in but I'll have
better numbers but certainly VT revenues
I would expect be much more than $95
million a year thank
you um I'm going to um have Senator Lang
come up for a minute because he's got a
he wants to say a few things then he has
sorry
again hi guys Senator Tim Lang um Senate
wayam me's chair uh I served on this
committee for my three terms in the
house as well um I just wanted to bring
some data to you I know as you're going
through hb2 things like the tax rate is
going to be a conversation and so I
brought along with me I specifically
reached out to the American gaming
Association which is the the national um
group that manages or or consults on
gaming
um as well as Spectrum gaming which was
our vendor we picked for the gaming
commission which I also served on um on
tax rates Nationwide so you can see what
taxes look like Nationwide what other
states are doing to as you compare New
Hampshire so the one thing I do want to
talk about it so uh you we passed in in
the Senate ways of Means Committee a
bill uh for video Lottery terminals um
last week it'll be on the floor this
Thursday our tax rate we set was 35% on
our tax rate and I just want to put some
logic and understanding to that and
actually make a recommendation to you I
probably would have made differently but
um if you recall under HHR you have a
25% tax rate that's the number under the
charitable gaming commission we learn
that the operational expense to the
owners are between 12 and 18% of the ggr
of the gross Gaming revenue so what I'd
recommend is you split that difference
and assume a 15% 12 18 middle is 15 and
then split that Revenue so that the
state will increase its tax rate from
25% to 37 uh 32.5% that's a 7 1.5%
increase the operators will also get a 7
and a half% bump in um their their
revenues so it splits the difference it
takes what a current tax rate of 25 so
it's not as painful to the operator the
one thing I I'll say is as you and the
reason why I'm I'm I'm recommending that
is because I can go to Encore and I can
bet 50 bucks and I can on a hand a
blackjack and if I win I win 50 bucks
and I can walk away I can go to any
charitable gaming casino in New
Hampshire I can bet 50 bucks and if I
win I get 50 bucks back so you're not
going to attract People based on just
pure gaming right that's not the reason
if I can go make $50 at encor I can go
make $50 here in New Hampshire it's
going to be what's closest and easiest
to me where you will make the difference
is the customer service experience right
so by giving operators more money they
make our casinos more fun for lack of a
better phrase more staff more food and B
more entertainment values more things so
we want to come underneath the other
states when it comes to our tax rate
because we want to encourage our invest
our our gaming operators to put money
back into the facility to make it more
fun so that guy who's in Boston instead
of driving over to Encore if you've ever
made that drive it's almost impossible
to get there the way that that casino's
off the interstate but it'll say I'm
just going to drive up to Nashville I'm
going to drive up to Salem and I'm going
to I'm going a game and we'll bring more
tax revenue from um the states of
Massachusetts and the state to main into
New Hampshire because a our casinos will
be nicer they'll be more fun they'll be
more entertaining because the operators
have the revenue they need the
operational money to be able to make it
better rather than just be the same as
Encore so um so my recommendations is
when you're thinking about this tax rate
think about the um around 32 and a half%
like I said the Senate passed 35 that
was my negotiating position with the
house because I know you passed 30 and I
was hoping you meet me in the middle um
at 32 and A2 if we went to committee a
conference um but but as you're looking
at hb2 I'd consider that understand it's
going to have a major impact on the
budget right if you drop the tax rate
from 45% to 32 a. half% uh 12 a half%
decrease in revenues um and so some of
the other things are going to have to be
looked at over in finance but as a but
as a tax policy not looking at the
spending side but just looking as a
policy I'd encourage you to look around
around 35 to 32 and a half% cuz uh the
last again I think it's fair The
Operators will make a little bit more
the state will make a little bit more
the Charities will make a little bit
more everybody makes a little bit more
money by going to 45 The Operators will
actually lose money as compared to HHR
um they'll they'll go from a 25 to a to
a uh
45% and if you assume that they're at
the maximum at 18 um they're still going
to lose 2% of Revenue every every uh
year just by choosing to go to slots so
no operator is going to want to do that
so we have to think about the business
side uh make sense um
so I guess that was it I'm happy to take
questions if you have any Revenue splits
I'll leave to you I did mine differently
I I I I did a 25 2550 I gave 25% to
education I gave I created a new
reimbursement fund for municipalities um
to give 25% of Gaming revenue for slots
to back to municipalities who give out
the elderly tax credit because as you
know when you give out a tax credit in
the state every other property taxpayer
picks up the cost of that tax credit um
and so my idea was we could help local
property taxes by reimbursing
communities for these elderly tax
credits they give and it would be a
prorated amount based on how much is in
the fund and then they give 50% to the
general fund for whatever purposes the
legislature deems
appropriate questions for Senator Lang
yes repr
opal thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you Senator
um I don't remember the exact figures
but as I recall from some previous
information we received I believe from
representative om
uh New Hampshire already charges a
significantly lower license fee than any
of our surrounding states and as I
remember help me remember but I think
our fee is like
$250 the the fees for our neighboring
states are in the thousands if not tens
of thousands if not more is that correct
that's a true
statement is that not already an
attraction I know that not an attraction
for the
customer but correct in terms of in
terms of operators I would think that
would be a pretty strong incentive to
build here or to to create casinos here
as opposed to having to pay the
Commonwealth sure so I I look at it this
way one's a short-term fee right so you
could you could charge you know big big
upfront cost but in the end you're going
to have to lower your tax rate because
these guys still got to make a living
and they going to have to pay off that
they're going to take loans on that it's
going to add into their operational
expense operational expenses so you
could charge a big fee and it it will
create a barrier for people coming into
the state to invest in this state to
expand in this state especially if you
do a variable size some states have
variable size gaming licenses tiered
tiered licenses they call them sometimes
um but again that's going to be a
barrier to entry into the state um so
you could do that but I think it would
it would actually hinder us more I I'm
I'm more of a long-term player I'm going
to look at a reasonable tax rate that
will allow them to keep our our Gaming
facilities fresh fun and operational by
giving the operators a little more money
um remember some of these gaming
operators I was I was at the Nash opened
up last week um and I went to their
grand opening to to see it down in nsha
um they have they have 600 employees
about 350 to 400 a full-time right so
these are adding I don't want to create
barriers for people to come open up in
our state if they're going to create you
know 450 new jobs or you know 600 new
jobs in our state so uh I'm not a big
fan of of Entry fees I prefer to take a
long-term look at it followup Mr chair
all I guess I'm not thinking necessarily
in terms of
matching um you talked about you know
putting our our um tax rate beneath our
neighbors um I'm just wondering seems
like there may be some room to put our
licensing fee beneath our neighbors as
well let me ask you one other question
um I I don't know whether
hb2 I don't see an address in here but
um I'm I'm wondering about your thoughts
on the transferability of these licenses
once once you have a
license if you sell the business do you
sell the license as well thank you for
the question so again um licenses are
non-sellable you can only it's like any
other business it's an asset of the
business and if you sell your business
the asset goes with the business but I
can't sell that asset off on its own
so I have to sell the entire
business thank
you anything
else I don't see any thank you very much
thoughts we have Dr uh we are on we're
still on the VT section we're talking
yeah yes we are
discussing uh on page 39 from line 20 to
36 and well let me
see
um I don't think we have anything to say
yes I've just been looking at um section
66 about the commission and the members
I do
see on line 31 that no member of the
commission shall have any pecuniary or
other interest Etc but there is no
definition or no recommendation here as
to who would be a member of this
commission I understand it's the
government the governor's
decision but uh I would like to see some
language in there at some point about
who else might be on
suggestion I do
okay it could be one of two uh systems
and in my thought and I agree that uh
that's a kind of a b appointed by the
governor that yeah we it's normal yeah
that's true but uh um representative Aly
is aware of some issues we had with the
Liquor Commission that was three
members uh and it took U
uh Bill to U Bill O'Brien um to break
that down and change it over
um three members one from the house one
from the Senate one appointed by the
governor makes
sense if not
that then establish a joint uh Committee
of House and Senate Ways and Means as a
legislative oversight committee uh to
work and to oversee daily
operations of uh well not daily
operations but to to oversee the uh
strategic analysis of uh uh of the the
gaming in New Hampshire to give uh both
uh the commissioner a bit of uh guidance
and to uh make it more expeditious when
it comes before the uh legislature with
uh I want to sell
a Min a trillion dollar coin as a former
president once suggested to solve the uh
deficit issue uh which never happened
I'm just saying it would work a little
bit smoother than it currently does with
the commissioner and the Senate coming
up with a 35 and he knows the house
position is 30 and he's hoping to
committee a conference just work it out
ahead of time and get it done and that
would be done through an oversight
committee uh something of that nature Mr
chair I think needs to be urged upon uh
finance committee when they're talking
about this for the uh efficient
implementation of VI lottery in the
state robone El
me yes
um first um just remember this is an
existing
statute to which is being added only and
gaming and then at the bottom that the
commission shall be properly addressed
as the New Hampshire Lottery and gaming
um The Lottery Commission already
has three
Commissioners named by the governor at
its
top who are
overlooking our great long-term Lottery
executive director
who probably has more knowledge than
they did
do I'm not sure um and to add yet
another group which is are they going to
oversee the
Commissioners that are legislators who
may or may not
continue this year next year the year
after that or drop out to take a
job yes because the legislature is the
top dog not a commission which was a
problem we had with uh several
Commissions in the state and I again
mention the issues we had had in the
past and you know you had a uh liquor
Commissioners under the three that just
said we're not going to tell you
anything we don't report to you well he
doesn't tell us some things either he
says it's a contract and we can't find
out so well anyway um
but but I do think it's a lot of
unnecessary
bureaucracy especially considering that
all of us are on twoyear
terms which is a good thing which is a
good
thing but I mean is this really a a a
new commission or is it just because the
the bold face is and gaming so there's
already a state Lottery Commission is it
yeah yes okay that that's the commission
that oversees the day-to-day operations
more or less month-to month operations
but we're not creating a another another
commission no it would not be a
commission of that but uh if you grant
Jud uh judicial if you grant legislative
oversight to a body then you you have a
body already existing to help modify
this as we go through the birthing uh
Pains of establishing
uh BLTs and uh
um modifying uh whatever else comes
whatever else come yeah thank you
representative
shamberg representative ol could you
simplify this for me okay it says a
gaming Commission of three members you
stated one would be appointed by the
house one by the Senate one by the
governor I just want to make sure I'm
hearing this go on sir yes I'll that
would be one thing to add into this okay
you it would be one thing to add to this
because when I read the rest of it the
governor can remove by cause I go she
the governor would be overruling
whatever the house decides or the Senate
decides who that person shall be but you
you most Commissioners uh in the state
are removed only by
cause uh like safety commissioner and
except if you're dick Flynn and you know
where all the never mind uh but if you
were appointed if you were appointed and
the governor wanted to remove you would
that
be interference by another uh Department
of the government yeah I think it might
be did it that way we could do it okay
but I'm I'm saying we could do it which
is why probably go to legislative
oversight because that puts us in a
position of making a referral
thank
you representative elberger thank you Mr
chairman can we find out who the
Commissioners are not necessarily their
names but their backgrounds and that
information and how often they show up
pardon how often they show up uh it
varies um I've had a number of
Commissioners in the past generally they
have business backgrounds uh the current
three commission members are Deborah
Douglas who lives in BO um business
background she was a account person with
Marl
Lynch um Andy Cruz who you may know is a
former principal at AutoFair uh and a
number of other businesses and Earl
Pierce who are members of this body
probably know well he was a um
government relations expert with Telecom
um it's mostly been business the
governor uh Appo points generally would
the governor will call and ask if that's
okay he's asking permission he just
wants to make sure that we can work
together and I've never said no
obviously I've been fortunate I have
wonderful commission members appointed
by the governor and then they're
you represent
opal thank you Mr chairman actually this
is for representative erery um I'm just
trying to understand representative are
you talking about legislative oversight
as opposed to having the speaker appoint
one member and the Senate President
appoint one member is that yes as
opposed to that okay yes it would uh it
would be more clear that they can do
whatever they want but the ultimate
power for the the operations the
oversight would remain General
Court in this side of the house thank
you remember the governor occupies the
office in in the the uh uh State House
on our permission there's a reason we
have an executive councel still to this
day as well so that's yes that's true
too and trying to explain that to
yes rosan Murphy thank you Mr chairman I
had a couple of um I guess comments on
this one is that you know um Senator
Lang had mentioned that they were going
to try and or he was recommend dividing
the revenue 25% to the education trust
fund 25% to municipalities and 50% to
the general fund but I don't see
municipalities mentioned in where
they're talking about dividing the
revenue so so we also we had a public
hearing this morning on HB
728 okay uh and that is a potential area
where um he I talked to Senator Lang at
lunch and he there's a bill coming
through the Senate that is very very
similar to
728 um but there's a couple differences
one is it talks about those splits so we
could put those splits in 728 if we want
um because keep in mind everything
doesn't have to be an hp2 hb2 may you
know outline a few things it may not
describe everything that's why these
these other bills like
728 uh have the although that has to be
that has to be out of our committee by
the end of next week so um we may not be
able we may or may not be able to get
that all figured out uh but there
there's that um the 30 the 35% he was
talking about is in his bill um the 30%
is in 728 right now okay so that those
are the sorts of things and I think
there was one other difference but those
are the sorts of things that we can
Define there as well we don't have to
figure out everything within here could
I have followup please sure uh thank you
Mr chairman um the other concern I have
is that it's my understanding that the
teachers pensions do not have colas
currently and so my recommendation would
be rather than funding the department of
safety with any surplus that we um
improve the disparity between the
pensions that the teachers are getting
and the pensions that other government
employees are getting because it's
really getting to be pretty pretty wide
that's is that a f that's more of a
not yeah well that is on the first page
I mean where you going to put the money
okay well I
that's we're spitballing right now so
yeah yeah represent me I'd like to I'd
like to spitball back then because I
think that we can exercise legislative
oversight it by a full committee that
includes a range of people from from uh
and in public uh that includes a bunch
of people from different walks of life
and and different
interests uh whereas if we have a
threepers oversight committee the rest
of us have no idea what's going on and
no say in it oh no I I tend to agree
with you I don't I'm not limiting this
to three people uh my proposal it could
be a joint committee uh between uh House
and Senate ways and means our meeting
joint session or something all you need
to do is designate and or lot in law the
ability to do that that's the only thing
I would require how you know U having a
public is is was one of the reasons for
it uh because we are dealing with the
so-called syntax type situation and
because we have some EXP parents with
so did I'm just I don't want to have
what happened happen
again so I mean right now there is a
three-person commission how's that how's
that been working out I mean well in 10
years we've tripled revenue from 60 60
some million to 207 million so I think
well and there was a certainly a
discussion back in 2015 when we absorbed
the racing and charitable gaming
commission and they had six members and
they all wanted to join us and have a
nine member commission to which I
thought that would be
unwieldy nine commission members is
difficult to answer to you spend a lot
of time on the phone just answering
questions and letters and emails it's um
the larger certainly in my experience
nationally Lottery commissions that are
two dozen three dozen members gets very
unwieldy in terms of operations
okay I mean I just to be clear I mean
I'm I'm assuming this is the same this
is the same commission it's just that
it's it's being called
Theiss sorry they're just amending the
the change in the title of the just
adding gaming this this commission's
existed for many many years I you know
it's it's a recognition of the fact that
the whole game industry is changing
rapidly
okay yeah it shouldn't instead of
addressed if it was if we were in
England it would be called
title okay
sure uh yes Brier sorry I didn't mean to
interrupt uh m is a clarification I
think if I'm just asking for a
clarification is what we're discussing
now is we have an existing commission
that already exists are we talking about
amending that commission to enlarge it
and include legislative members just
from my understanding well we're we're
just throwing throwing out ideas I don't
know and that's why I just asked how's
the three- member commission working it
sounds like it's working fine at the at
the current moment so I would if
something's working follow up is broken
I I also believe that the commission
members make about between 10 and 15,000
in a year right the two commission
members make 10 a year and the chairman
yeah any other anything else um any
other comments on page
39 I mean right right now I I I took
three notes I guess one is there's a
suggestion for
opin or opt out opt-in opt out language
uh number two was to cross out the word
Governor um because this is coming from
the house on line 20 and then the third
suggestion
was
um oh well I guess the the How would how
are these chosen now these three members
of the commission is the governor
chooses them yes the resume submitted to
the governor uh resume submitted to the
governor governor chooses and then
appointed and then confirmation proces
executive counsel okay so do we I guess
I'm not clear on that did we want that
to change to represent UL suggestion of
one from the
add somewhere above or to the side
of the side of to the side of yeah if
you
if if we don't say that the
legislature can look
at either liquor or or um
gaming
then experience up here has taught me
that one of the
agencies may just get their hackles up
and tell you to go
away not necessarily current current
Personnel not entitled I believe there's
a bill pending for another study
commission um and it's legislatively
populated didn't know if you could add
that to that
yeah added to that um group because it
is a legislative body I'm a member but
I'm not voting right so and as you
remember from the study commission you
were on Mr chairman you know we staff it
and we're responsible for it and we
answer to it so it's not as if um would
be you'd be creating a third commission
something that in
that yeah well we may I guess the point
being we may not need to create another
um no but if if because that that that
commission does uh look at all these
things and if we give that commission
legislative authority to be an oversight
commission just what the Lang language
of a legislative oversight shall reside
in you're not creating anything other
than what we're already
section
yes I don't know if that already passed
or not we already have the authority
to look
at uh anything any group that is is
raising money for us once every two
years you have the authority to call us
back if you see anything or someone else
comes to you saying they've seen
something uh
and and have a meeting with the
executive director or I oppose the
Commissioners I don't know whether we've
never seen the Commissioners
so uh whether they'd get upset but um
and that allows the entire
committee
to which represents lots of different
interests to see and and discuss this we
can get to the point where you say
that's the contract we are allowed to
show you which is frustrating from my
side
but uh but that's something we'd get to
with anyone I
think uh and I don't know that
legislative oversight would allow us to
break contract
confidentiality no probably not but it
would only be three
people or five people or whatever no I
I'm I'm suggesting that in some fashion
we document or place in Granite that the
legislature has
oversight
period and this is just one way to do it
um I
would make that recommendation to
finance we have the commit uh commission
that is being established I think it
already passed the
house uh and we could of course modify
like we do all the time in the trailer
bill yeah uh just a simple sentence of
legislative oversight shall
reside I
I just history
has okay I I remember the frustration
both you and and Norm had with with
individuals and and I I felt it as
well but for whatever reason and it was
bad enough that well you know they took
that special commission that bill set up
and I sat on
that representative
Opel i u i I hate to disagree with
representative ol because under normal
circumstances I I I am all in favor of
legislative oversight for example I'd
love a little more legislative oversight
over efas but
more I I did I did um thanks to my
colleague um but and i' I've lost where
this has gone but is there not uh a
either a new rule or or something
regarding the ability of the legislature
through the speaker to subpoena and
would that not provide the kind of I
mean if if if an agency is going to wave
us off it seems to me that that you know
one way to one way to deal with that is
to go to the speaker and say
um but like I say I'm I'm generally all
in favor of legislative
oversight
yes you're absolutely correct if we had
authority
to so you're proposing Authority in hb2
right okay representative Aly I'm
wondering if our researcher has any
idea
uh what we would need to do if any
anything to create this concept which I
thought already existed of
oversight up to
you
different ways in other committees
commission UC
committee also um so having that within
Unusual issues that followview i' have
to look up yourit rulle to see exactly
how that spelled out but um it's
certainly you certainly have precedent
for that kind of activity if you're
Comm representative Southworth uh thank
you for taking my question it's more of
a comment but um I'm just thinking can
we refer um this section 66 this issue
maybe one of the leaders a two Pats
committee so that they be thinking about
this as well I know they already have a
list but um there seems to be the way
we're discussing it a way we may be able
to use that committee to to solve this
problem
commission it's confusing because this
is has the word Commission in it too but
it's a different commission that might
be able to tie up some loose
ense but someone needs to let Patrick
know so well okay first off he's not the
chair right now right U the new the new
commission needs to get started and
they'll appoint a chair maybe him again
uh but right now yeah but because it's
in limbo I'd suggest him but whatever
yeah yeah okay yeah I mean that that's
that that's um certainly another
possibility here is that commission
which is made up of legislators Senators
house members and members of the public
but um and director
McIntyre um the AG's office but there
you and the AG's office are non- voting
members uh we also had uh Al no you
weren't on the no I remember you're
sitting in the audience
though um so yes that that that
commission could study what
um yeah what should be done in this
regard because they'll already have more
information about some of these things
we're bouncing around as part of their
charge of what works and what doesn't
work
yeah um like I so we're not making we're
not writing the law we're just making
recommendations yeah well we can make
can right we're we're right we're not
going to necessarily vote on I'm just
trying to get a consensus of what we
think here we're not going to vote on
this we're not going to submit it well
we're going to submit our thoughts or
I'll submit our thoughts to um to
finance and say Here's how we'd like to
see this change and we'd like to see to
represent ul's Point um some sort of
oversight
um
yes light put your light on please
listen this conversation uh I it would
proably we already I I think we have the
mechanism in place with that commission
that we talked about that we passed out
of here and pass the floor yeah um maybe
that through this we could tweak that to
uh have some oversight Authority um to
address the concerns that are coming up
in this uh discussion also uh I believe
that the LBA has a performance audit
section and a financial section that can
come in and look at the these operations
that and they can look at any contract
statute yeah I'm not sure that we'd put
the commission uh charitable Gaming
Commission in in this area only because
I mean someone can certainly disagree
with me but this is
more
um if I'm I don't know it just it
doesn't feel yeah it doesn't feel LBA
audit team is in my building six months
a year and so they create the management
letter for our annual report and then we
produce annual report with the findings
actually it's this month so we're the
most audited agency in the state by LBA
okay um yes represen elberger than
opal I I wanted to get back to revenue
okay unless you want to stay with this
no I I was just about to say I think
we're done with this page but represent
opal
no I I just um was going to before we
finish Mr chair if you could just sort
of
review what you what you would include
in the the list of of things I missed I
missed part of that list okay so for
page
39 the it's the last half of page 39 is
what we've been talking about um the S
we're going to suggest that they be
VT um
laws um we were going to suggest that we
cross out the word Governor here which
I'm sure they'll catch anyhow but we'll
make that suggestion on line 20 and the
third suggestion on this page was that
some legislative oversight be uh put
into
the the language of this
commission thank you so that's that's
all I had for that is everyone okay with
that okay I'm coming sorry sorry yeah Mr
chairman I'm I'm just com circling back
again to them specifying so I looked at
that 728 bill that this refers to and
it's kind of confusing because the
allocations are different like between
the two bills they're not you know
Senator Lang presented one set of
allocations in percentages and then if
you look at 728 it's a different
allocation so I'm not clear on what's
going to actually pass into law if you
know what I mean so so that's yeah
that's um so basically what happens is
that's outside of this particular thing
but what Senator Lang is talking about I
don't know the number of the bill he was
talking about but that'll go through the
Senate if it passes it'll come to the
house we'll most likely get it here um
if
um if we change so for an example if we
change something in that Senate bill or
we pass 728 and they change something in
the house bill uh there ends up being a
committee of conference between the two
bodies to come to agreement on
what well sometimes they don't come to
agreement but if they do then then great
so we don't we don't really what he was
talking
about doesn't really matter too much of
what we're looking at right now because
we're just looking at the language here
in hb2 and what we would change or add
if
any follow so just quickly like so again
my comment on you know the funding the
department of safety on line 24 versus
leaving that to the discretion of the
group or improving the disparity between
the teachers pensions that you know
because they're having Recruitment and
Retention problems too particularly in
special ed which is a mandate it's a
federal mandate so I think that you know
we need to do something to like improve
the situation there because it's
creating a lot of um you know
dissatisfaction if you will that I'm
getting feedback from like constituents
on so I'm just concerned that okay then
you like to change that to I'd like to
fund a cola for the teachers pensions
because they don't have one right now so
and with the inflation that we've been
experiencing you know in the last
several years it's a big concern not
fund but contribute contribute to yes
yeah okay so I guess how would we word
that if people are in agreement do we
say funding the department of safety
equal equal amount well do they figure
out would fin Finance would figure out
what that funding balance is we're just
suggesting that you also fund
the that's all okay so so we say
Department of Safety
comma uh what is it again Cola or
contributing to uh teachers col yeah
they don't get one so I think we should
um to their pension system or something
to just improve the you know like I said
they the the two pensions keep going
further and further apart in terms of
equity and so I think we we're going to
exacerbate a perception on the part of
the teachers that they're being
mistreated by the state and I don't want
to see that happen especially the
special Educators because we just can't
get enough do we what do we call them
though is it just the blank word
pension okay yes it' be group one then
yeah okay raised separately by the
governor every now and then but the
teachers
okay so I'm going to put comma
contributing to group one teachers what
cola or no teach one group one
teachers okay retir
retirement
that okay let's let's uh move on to uh
page
40 all right Mr chairman yeah yes I
wanted to get back to finance to revenue
though for just a moment um yeah sure um
I I am really hopeful that your
estimates about the revenue that will be
generated by VTS are under estimates
quite
honestly I'm not sure what happens on
the off chance that they are not that
the revenue that is projected to be
generated by the VTS will make up for
the loss of basically $95
million to the education trust fund and
I I'm not sure where or
how but I would like to figure out a way
to have a um representative we're we're
on on page 39 there's nothing about that
is that somewhere else no that's why I
said I wanted to get back to it I asked
the commissioner
about the estimates that we have from Dr
yeah about revenue and on the last page
the chart indicates that the education
trust fund will be uh the funding will
be reduced by 94.9 million because of uh
changes in distributions from BET let's
get on the same page so where so you're
looking at the Dr handout the Dr handout
the last page the last page
and where we on the last page you oh the
94.9 million yes
okay
uh okay what's causing the uh now if you
go back to page one it talks about
changes in distribution from the
business profit tax the business
Enterprise tax the tobacco tax and the r
oh okay I think this is because the
governor yeah we haven't gotten to this
section yet the section you're talking
about is where the percentage goes from
41% to 34% correct so we're getting to
that we haven't gotten to that yet all
right at some I'd like to just sort of
put a a placeholder in yeah that when it
gets to that point that we need to
consider what happens if the additional
projected Revenue isn't there and there
is this law a potential loss yes to the
education trust represent elme yes I
just just like to point out that on when
the budget comes out it will have
specific numbers for everything in it uh
if the revenues do not cover that which
they did not during the four years that
I was first chair of ways and means on
then in the second year we did another
budget in the third year we did the
normal budget in the fourth year we did
another budget because the recession
kept on getting
worse it would go up a little in anyway
well that and that's why and when uh
when that happens the legislature the
finance committee has to come back and
figure out where it is cutting and if
there's any place that we could raise
some Revenue that everybody would agree
to
which is also very hard
okay to uh let's go to page
40 so page 40 the first half of page
definitions yeah definition wager games
of
chance let's just make this line 12 and
13 just m it's yeah
Power well let's ask about that so um on
page four do you do you have this you
have this right so page 40 uh line 12
and 13 what is that obviously it's about
licensing but I mean
what
you I'm just verifying that you're
correct
um
us surveillance appr by
us
okay okay thank
you okay so it's in the second let's
look at the second half un let's does
anyone have any questions on the first
half of that
page okay second half starts with
chapter 287 J video Lottery ter
terminals
definitions I guess well actually this
that's all that's all definitions yeah
does
I I when I looked at this weekend I
underlined at line 20 to be eligible for
vl2 license the
applicant must have been licensed or
eligible for license sh to sell par
Mutual
pools oh yeah so I guess my question is
there so the only way you can get a VT
license okay
right represent elme so so they sorry
line so that number is finite at this
point that it's not open-ended anymore
no okay would there be a point where you
would like to uh let us know how many
are in that
queue certainly it's because like I said
understand
but yeah but this but to our discussion
earlier about the seven years 2031 this
is fixed until
2031 at the moment yes at the moment
well unless the next unless the
legislature changes it it's it's 2031
representative
Opel um I I just in that same uh section
on line
22 um and I I like this but it says a
license shall not be permitted to be
transferred or sold which it seems to me
would be different from what Senator
Lang was saying that in fact if if
someone holds a license presently and
sells their business as I read this and
I think this should be the
case the business could be sold but the
license would not be sold it would be so
the the this language exists now in law
under HHR and the AG said that while the
license like if you were hack the licens
into Boston you could sell that license
and had had value but now you have to
buy the entire business both assets and
liabilities and so that's been um a bit
troubling new outfits but certainly the
business gets sold and the license you
maintain is transferred with the
business so so the license can be sold
as long as you sell it with the business
it's more the business can be sold and
license goes with it but yes the answer
is yes so it's the same thing that
Senator langu was saying yeah yeah that
okay follow up
yeah um my my question then is let's
assume I own I I am a current license
holder I have a casino that I'm
operating or historic horse
racing and I choose to sell that
business the whole kitten kabo to XYZ
gaming if I'm selling the whole business
including the
license where does the Lottery
Commission come in in terms of vetting
that
that buyer and and I know that there's
been a lot of news coverage about just
that very issue but I'm I need to I've
been reading it and now I need to
understand it better um generally very
very early in the process they would
come to us um experienced gaming
operators are used to this in fact they
already know the hundred documents they
need to give us and have it in a box
ready to go um it's very rare to get an
inexperienced gaming operator because
these facilities do sell for large sums
of money so we start the vetting process
very early um Financial criminal
business operations visit their
facilities all of it so it's a it's a
very detailed uh process and and folks
there are folks who have not got through
would have been
rejected one last
followup
um are there states where the license is
not transferable even if the business is
sold
is not
transferable and if and if you need to
not that I don't I don't know all the
the 30 some odat states that do gaming
um like I know in New Jersey there's a
limit on number you can own you can only
own three um obviously tribal you have
to be the tribe so those don't count um
and every so often sometimes these are
bit out like Rhode Island is a bid
process with the state the Twin Rivers I
believe the facilities in Mass can be
sold uh I know that main they can be
sold because they were sold the
applicant for the axid license um Mr Bob
bear sold it to Churchill DS so
um just going in my head on Ron New
all repres
Aly
um yes
uh I I was look I I still I is there any
place where it defines what to be
eligible uh licensed or eligible to be
eligible for
lure or do we just know what it means
and go along with that sorry my mic's
off certainly eligible operators j4
Roman numeral one that to me spells out
who is eligible and it had to have been
a historic horse racing ly as of the
effective day of this chapter had to be
either licensed or eligible for licenser
this is J nj4 somewhere yes page 41
20 uh
here but well it
doesn't well it says under RSA under
under two it it says what you have to do
in order to do that I presume yes that
that's the our authority to do the
background check we require of the
applicants
okay and my other question or rather
remark is
that uh the commission with the
assistance of the Attorney General and
the chief of staff of any city or town
where license facilities are located
shall administer and enforce the
provisions of this chapter we don't get
any money for that do
we no I think it's more protecting the
money that we're getting
legally we don't get money legally from
this is from the it goes to the state it
goes to the you mean the city town I'm
yeah
ah representative uh did shamber did you
have your light on okay
elberger thank you both um I want to go
back to line 22 because the way that is
written at the uh at the end of that
line a license shall will not be
permitted to be transferred or
sold simply says it can't be transferred
or sold there's no provision stated in
here that it cannot be um shall not be
permitted to be transferred or sold
unless it's part of selling a business
and I would absolutely want to see
language that indicates that because
right now it says you simply can't
transfer to well that must be somewhere
right where where is it that it's just
in uh opinion we receed from the
Attorney General's office related to
can't limit it's part of the business
and that business can be sold and that B
it's you didn't transfer it because ABC
Corp still owns it ABC Corp is now sold
to another company it's still called ABC
Corp still holds the same number of
things it had before assets and
liabilities uh it was not our decision
it's a it was a legal opinion so what
you're saying is it's not necessarily
specific
to um casinos casinos it's like any any
asset so when a business is sold all the
assets and liabilities go to the new
yeah that's just common business prti
corre most of the time you you want to
buy the assets not the liability so
usually just buy the equipment because
you don't want to buy any unforeseen
liabilities but stops you from just
buying the yes but in this instance you
have to buy the liabilities it's one of
the issues related to number lienes is
you're buying at all it's like buying a
land so this is more part OFA the answer
to your question is it's already in what
case law or I don't know how you would
it was in opinion we said because the
we're the first applicant who went to
sell the business from the same company
just to sell it somebody else we
submitted to the General's office our
compliance officer did five years ago
four years ago and uh that's the opinion
we were given yeah
okay sh thank you Mr
chairman
director thinking out of the box here I
just had a podiatrist work on my feet
okay I went into the office and I saw a
license on the wall mhm if that
podiatrist sells that business is that
license on the wall stay there for that
business or is it go with the owner of
the business who has the degree and
things like that uh I'm having a hard
time this English language is supposed
to be simple and it is simple that's so
so m i
could the ability to apply for the
license is what you're buying from the
business so it's not I'm not
transferring your license saying here
this this is belongs to you now you have
to go through the vetting process to be
eligible to it but you are not eligible
for it so the new because because in
your example a podiatrist another
podiatrist could buy the
business they could buy the business
which is the building but they would
have to be licensed correct correct it's
similar to us we buy the business and
you still they can still buy the license
but com with the
business but the new the new person that
bought or the new entity that bought the
business has to be licensed has to get
approved has to go full full like
they're like okay great I got my license
I'm all set they still have to get
approved yeah as well and we like I said
we have rejected individuals in that
process directly all right good uh I
mean not good that you rejected just
good that we can uh we solve that
rejecting um excellent okay what else on
this page um I I jumped down to line 35
and I said VTS shall not accept wages in
excess of
$25 which in my mind I thought maybe
that should be 50 because didn't we
raise games of chance to 50 or which one
we raised something to table States
table this is every second that you're
pushing that button and you're doing
another 25
bucks so it adds up
fast that's what back
UPS okay opinion opinions on that 25
actually if you're playing Blackjack
that goes by pretty fast
though so what do you think about
faster I have no problem with okay
people like 25 but it's up to 25 a lot
of people might do five yeah yeah no I
mean like coin Opera machines are so
much better you can get nickels
dyes the represent early the load
capacity for the for the count room is
brutal we we've broken buildings with
coins in our
industry any any other thoughts comments
so where uh so before we move on what is
so we have no I guess we have no
correct I'd like to suggest
that the city or town in which these
things are you be getting at least some
compensation for everything they have to
go through why don't we pay them at the
all right um yeah I think changes like
that might have to come through a
through a separate bill I'm thinking
that we can suggest that all we want I'm
in yeah but an opt in and opt out those
that's already coming through in other
bills that have been passed 24 7 went
through unanimously we just passed uh
737 737 the chief police out of this
four because the commission and the
Attorney General are paid by the state
but the chief of
police is in a bind if he has to have
somebody always there when he's on 12
shifts
well I feel like we're going to go down
a rabbit hole on this one uh represent
Amy I don't necessarily disagree with
you but um I think how how however their
language allowing the chief of police to
uh do detail work at the facility for
the purpose of enforcing should be clear
well that would be well they would get
get paid for that yes right yeah they
could to that point most of the rooms do
hire police departments for details
particularly on weekends regular I'm
just kind of thinking that's what the uh
age limit I mean they're not going to
get into the technical uh analysis of a
slot machine but you got to be 21 you
got or 18 or whatever it yeah and you
you can't be drunk and and all these
facilities have significant Securities
departments they really do really
really they have to well they don't want
things to get out of control yeah yeah
all I think uh you might uh recommend to
them that the language uh be more clear
work
okay very good
page
42 and bear has was in the
game pardon bear was in the gaming he
was the original owner of Oxford track
in Oxford Maine that he was the
applicant for the license uh and
received a gaming license and opened up
Oxford Casino and the French family let
him do
that I he was in Maine the NASCAR yeah
yeah he wasn't he was not longer than
NASCAR owner but he was the yeah
well all right I'll um I need to uh
correct myself from what I said earlier
on Senator Langs uh the stuff I said
this what he's talking about is in is
what we'll deal with 728 but I I forgot
on page 42 line six that's one of the
things he was addressing in his bill um
and he was also addressing in line 13
and 14 the percentages um so I just
wanted to correct myself out so we are
going to look at that now um so on line
six
one on minimum average daily aggregate
payback of 88% as I
recall that is lower than any of these
use yeah it's a um represent it's a
minimum so it's really a consumer
protection I know that sounds ironic in
this context but it's really to make
sure that the operators in a location
where there's no other competition don't
have lower payouts to make a so that
thinking if there was one in Berlin
correct one in Bur yeah one in yes one
in an isolated location like Conway
um none of them have been running on
that no they're all about 90% yeah you
percent fall back position
okay if anyone does anyone have anything
on lines two through
five before I go to line six okay line
six uh 45% is what the governor has put
in uh her budget um from what we heard
from Senator Lang that's probably a non
a nonstarter for these businesses to
even take a chance um on New
Hampshire um so this in in his bill he's
got 35%
and in the bill we have 728 it's
currently
30% um that's the bill we heard this
morning public hearing um so what do we
want to recommend I mean I'm in some
ways we're getting ahead of ourselves
because we just heard this bill this
morning and I know this isn't the bill
we heard but this is a component of the
bill we heard um and it sounds like from
what Senator Lang's discussions have
been is that he did he recommend 32 and
a now he was yes um but he's got 35
going he's got 35 right now got 35 going
through so it's it's you
know um representing Murphy uh committee
the conference back rooms nobody knows
what's going on um until it comes out
then you're agree or disagree those the
only votes you have so what he's saying
what rep Senator Lang had suggested was
he can get it passed in Senate at
35 we just got it passed out of here at
30 no we we didn't pass anything yet
well we're the bill proposes 30 the bill
proposes 30 so some halfway between is
32 and a half which is where it will
likely come out if we don't bother with
anything so don't
bother at this point you can recommend
if I could Mr chairman the the 45 the 45
number was at my suggestion given the
existing Marketplace in the U um New
England and the fact that there are
really three economic levers for
sighting a casino there's what you pay
up front is a tax rate what you pay I
mean a license fee what you pay as a
going rev share model and then what you
make them do and New Hampshire is at the
lowest end of all three of those
functions we don't charge a license fee
or Le
$750 we don't make them do anything
Capital wise uh whereas in Boston they
made Encore build a $2.4 billion do
casino and our rate at 25% is the lowest
in New England um amongst all operators
where Maine and Vermont Main's at 46 and
49 the plane roid facility in
Massachusetts is at is at 49 R Island's
at 60 um Encore while they're at 25% %
did require $2.4 billion capital
expenditure and had $85 million license
fee um
so it was not a if we could do this over
again and if I have my time machine I
would go back and make the 25% on HHR
higher because their revenue numbers as
we're mind were based off of a per
machine tag of $150 per machine and now
they're running at two40 250 and the
Southern Tier it's over $300 a machine
and a lot of those capex cost are fixed
real estate's fixed the machine's fixed
you know they pay for the O the Box
itself is fixed obviously the content
costs extra money so I guess it's
a you know I view my job as making the
best deal I can for the state and so
that's why I suggested the number that I
did that's in here in
law I just wanted to make my sales pitch
I'm a Salesman for a living
so yes that was that was my number based
off of what I believed would be a fair
number and
I've not seen the math that disputes it
but that's without adjusting other types
of fees like you said a renewal fee ex
exactly like without any of those
numbers just per just just a straight
rev model like they do better we do
better um and there is a natural lift
with going from HHR to VT you folks
wouldn't see it but because of the math
because it uses different technology in
the back and I don't want to geek out
and bore you but it's much better and it
will have a a natural lift that
everybody will feel um and that's why I
suggested the number only said just to
make the best I could for the state well
the best number for the
State op just um two points you know in
in addition to the capex being lower
here um maybe not compared to Maine or
Vermont but certainly compared to
Massachusetts and Connecticut um and our
addressable Market is certainly bigger
than either Maine or Vermont yeah um you
know give as close as we are to Boston
and the rest of the North Shore um I I
would think that you know and and I
would particularly rely on the on the
director and his number um I think we're
already as he says I think we're already
selling ourselves cheap um in this area
and frankly we need the revenue um one
other thing and I may be jumping ahead
here Mr chairman if I if I am I
apologize but um and not to steal the
Thunder of my friend from Hanover
representative Spar um I do I do think
it would be helpful if we could somehow
and this may be outside our lane but um
suggest to the finance committee that
some mechanism for spreading the wealth
among Charities would be um should be
pursued yeah I don't think that'll
happen in the finance committee that
will probably happen in this a in the
commission okay um
yeah um I'm still here representative I
know yes I understand why you get drawn
to the right believe me um I'd like to
stay with 45 yeah I don't always agree
with the governor but I think that's a
good place to start because I think
there will be some compromises but I
would much rather start there than in
the 30s so that would be my
recommendation stick with 45 for now and
and that's Mr McIntyre's recommendation
too right and goe yes yes it it was was
as if I could redo it over again right
where versus the businesses having lost
something I wouldn't start hr25 now it
is where it is now it's in law looking
at our neighbors in Massachusetts it
says 49 I think so Mass there's a
facility called PL Ridge in for slot for
slots that said 49 plus 600 per per
machine $600 they pay per machine
correct which is a lot and they paid
they had the plane ridge had $125
million minimum capital investment um
and like I said Maine in Vermont sorry
not for on Maine the two facilities in
Maine Banger and Oxford are at 46 and
49% respectively and they also pay a fee
um yeah for machine and I also pay a
license I think it's $200,000 is
80 80,000 annually for license is that
is that a renewal is that the oh I'm
talking about the original application
oral okay and then there's I think the
uh thank you Mr chairman in my notes it
says that Senator Lang pointed out that
at
45% this might cause the operators to
lose 2% every year by going to the slot
machines can you address that please
certainly what he's suggesting is his
math isn't wrong it's
um they pay 25% now they pay a fee on
top of that 18% get to 43 at 45 there's
a 2% Gap but that doesn't take into
account that the migration of HHR to VTS
will minimally have a 10% lift and by my
math 30% lift and so there's a it's a
rising tide that lifts all boats and
here next okay next well I don't so I
don't know
what
we'll yeah I don't think we can really
vote on that percentage because I know
there's there's some who who do not like
this 45% so
probably yeah it's um we ended up with
no money from B because the Senate
way no
State well I think I think the issue is
I I can't talk to specifics but um I do
know of situations where this 45% is
going to cause
angst well more than angst
um business issues and what's that I
know what you mean not of so um yeah so
I think the the and it may be why the
Senate is at
35% but yeah so um thank you Mr chair so
do you think just targeting a number
slightly lower than
45 like 42 might be
no it's not going to fly so what the
what's like 35 is where it's going to
fly or 32 and a half or what I think I
think it's going to be what Senator L
suggested as a compromise of 32 and a
half is where it's going to end up so uh
well he was talking about line eight
you're talking about line no he's
talking about line six oh
no Lang was talking about line eight
we're talking about line six
understandable
no
35% it just happens to be that um that's
35% of 45% right right exactly I can I
can tell you with
99.9% shorty that he didn't he wasn't
talking about that 35% does it matter in
the um if we leave it at the governor's
number there's going to be a negotiation
they'll figure it out we can we can just
not make so we can make no comment yeah
yeah if that makes sense
yeah we can either recommend I I would
say right now we can either recommend 32
and a half or not recommend anything so
so we can't even say that that the
majority of us here think that it should
be
4 I I the problem with that the finance
committee is going to change it
any this isn't going to stand I don't
believe that it's going to stand well I
think given that we don't have uh enough
people here I think we don't make a
recommendation on that number well we're
not going to make a recommendation on
anything today anyway are we well
there's some things we we've agreed to I
can make a recommendation on I I asked
let me see if I have a response on
anything else because we don't have
enough people here um unless they'll
give us more time I I sent a text asking
how much time we have not received a
reply um so that's why I want at least
get as many positions that we agree on
if he says you have to have them by well
even if he says you have to have by the
end of the week we're out of time
because this is the only meeting we have
this week could we do um a poll again
and just see how many people are fine if
we do nothing just so you know
so we'll just leave it
alone no just this one thing the
45% yeah and so our straple isn't a big
debate it's that we aren't going to do
anything with it at this time we're just
leaving it yeah that'll give you backing
if people are saying why didn't we pick
okay yeah how many people think we
should just leave it as it is because
because if we come up with something
not we're passing over
it yeah I I I see the confusion but um
I'll have to make it clear to finance
that we I don't think we have enough
a no there's no point to it because we
don't have a a good representation
here same
represent I think we've lost another two
or three
people we already
we already voted to go along with
majority uh may make
it I don't believe it'll stay at
45%
um this may make it impossible to do
uh but there is the no I mean line 10 uh
because no matter what the percentages
line 10 is
still well no line do something
different with it which would be three
licensed charitable organizations or
four licensed charitable organizations
depending on how big that casino is so
maybe we should say up to there would be
more Charities that would be able to get
in on this
right that's that's fine so right now it
says well that would require increasing
if if we leave it at 45% if we increase
this to two uh two to four uh change it
from two to four no I wouldn't change it
to four because if you're a small small
Casino you can't do four how about uh so
it looks like it's already two at a
minimum so why don't we say much
contract with two to four licensed or
yeah that would be fine if if we're
leaving it at
45% in
again 45% is the gross that's the that's
the 100% that we distributed
right I don't know I don't think the two
are tied together I mean yes they are
because the 45% yes there's more money
if at 45% that's the point but but from
what director McIntyre is saying the
amount of money coming in on on some at
some of these casinos now is markedly
increased so whether it's 45% or 32% or
whatever it sounds like more money's
coming in don't forget HHR is what
currently at
25% and the more Charities that are
contracted the less each charity
gets yeah but some of these big casinos
get it come and tell us not to let
anybody else
in I would Rec that sounds familiar so
how about we say two to four is that
represent
elberger yeah at at the risk of needing
to go out wearing a a suit of armor to
keep various projectiles from getting to
me I honestly believe that the casino
should have no authority over who's
getting the money in the way of
Charities we have what something like
9,000 charities in the state and 900 of
them are getting money through
charitable gaming yeah so it's so being
on the commission it was recognized as a
problem that needs to be solved so my
suggestion would be that the casinos get
no authority over who gets the money
that the commission determine a system
for how the money gets
distributed which may include things
like everybody gets some small
percentage or we take turns over the
course of several years but that would
be the commit
decision it should not be left to the
casinos because they don't know the
people or the or the Charities that they
don't know and those Charities that they
don't know get nothing right no it is a
problem that's why and I would agree
100% with you uh representative but is
this the time and the place for it
that's what I just don't know that's
that's the issue because if we take it
away if we say let's get rid of it they
can't pick well who's now the Charities
don't get anything because then maybe
add at the end of this until such time
as the commission makes its
determination about how the funds should
be distributed so leave it until the
commission figures it out and maybe give
a and I'm sorry with the maybe but um
the commission is supposed to be
authorized or is authorized now has it
been um has the membership been
determined
no no because the commission the last
commission just finished up their work
with the report the new commission uh
still has to be appointed um I think I
think um so as I said it's already
recognized as a
problem it hasn't no it hasn't finished
it hasn't gone through the Senate yet
yeah so but the thing is it's recognized
as an issue it's written up in the last
report as something that needs to be
looked at so I think we've got to just
be very simple here the fact that we
don't say what you're suggesting uh repr
elberger doesn't this is still has to be
addressed because even if we say two to
four there's still the problem that's
still not going to cover all so it it's
just a matter of do we change this at
all do we leave it as two do we say two
to four uh I think we give yeah I think
let's give the option of of more and yes
the casino is going to decide who they
are but at least it it's something for
now I
mean it's not going to be if we just
take away that power then then charity
now does that make sense repres yeah
yeah I remember this I think
I asked uh representative Ames about
this with this
commission and wanted to get an answer
from
about this very question about how long
we'd be waiting to hear about a
recommendation on this
so to mess around with this right now
and to your
point no no charity gets anything is
danger I this is
we're this has been very frustrating for
me this whole
thing
uh I don't know how to move it forward
but I at two to four put something in
there now at least show the show show
that we're interested in seeing make a
statement somewhere that we want to see
more uh Charities get this especially if
there's going to be a lot more money
coming in according to the uh
director uh whoa I think we're in pretty
good shape to say that yeah my opinion
especially as that means that the
Charities that are already in the
pipeline are going to be getting a
windfall and the people the Charities
that don't get anything will continue
continue to get nothing there's no
improvement for them and I don't know
how to make a difference and I agree
with you it's it's messy saying that
they don't get to make the decisions at
this point means nobody gets anything I
I just would I don't know if it's
possible to say that there needs this
the gaming commission or
the needs to make up its mind about how
the distribution will be made and the
selection of Charities will be made
within x amount of time and if not then
we will designate some other group to
make that decision for them well it's so
it's in the it's in the the the last
report that that needs to be done is
there a timeline there's not a timeline
so the other option don't forget the
other option is if you can put together
a bill uh that you feel like solves the
problem or part of the problem then then
submit the bill because it'll probably
get heard before the commission makes a
recommendation so so for now I it sounds
like the consensus is two to four no
didn't didn't representative aim submit
a bill on not to exceed
50,000 for he was that his bill I think
it was yeah yeah we killed it
yeah just the
point it didn't really yeah we felt like
I think we bipartisan and get Langs
input it was a very bipartisan vote that
uh the K I like what you're saying two
to four at least even a minimum I'm good
with two to four I think it makes sense
I think that's Mak sense anybody object
to two to four no okay all right good
okay okay so what's next is um then on
line 13 and
14 13 and 14 uh the governor is
suggesting 50% go to the education trust
fund 50% to the general fund uh repes
represent of Lang Senator Lang was was I
guess what what did he do he did 25% to
the education trust fund and 25% to the
to a I don't know a fund that would help
uh that would go back to the communities
for property tax relief that that's the
discussion I between the two bodies I
like 5050 it'll pass the house that way
represent elberger at at the risk of
going back to what is an unsolvable
issue and I right now and I recognize it
I wonder if one approach in terms of how
many
Charities a uh facility a len has to
contract with might be approached in
terms of the size the the the revenue
that a facility has so that smaller
Casino knows have fewer Charities that
they are required to support where
larger ones are required to support more
and I'm playing with numbers I'm making
them up because I know they're wrong
well no I I agree with the principle of
what you're saying I just don't know how
we decide like if if we want to say up
to two if it's this but if you're over
this Revenue then it's got to be three
and then if you're over this it's four
but I don't I don't without further
study right now we don't have time on
our side I'm not sure how we figure that
out can I can I ask uh representative
mmes he has the you know 50% going to
the ETF 50% to group two is group two
basically part of the general fund is
that what that
means uh I don't know where that is
thought I was just trying to look at his
hp2 breakdown and compare that to this
HP to line 13 and
14 the one that he handed out that it's
this yeah does she have his is different
he broke it down differently than the
governor
yeah so is it she's paying group two
money I
another
don't is if you look at the the
I can only assume that me that's right
what's that's I agree too I'm just
saying the 50% jump in front of that
group two there I'm assuming that's
based on based on the
language this
is this isn't even right is it hb2
5050 I'm not sure the Govern oh this
yeah had these trust fund group two oh
he's putting all in group two 28 plus
15 is
um we're talking to
7 oh yeah right and just the 5050 split
you know if you look at represent so
looks like his supposed between the ETF
and group two I'm just wondering if if
he me group two to be general fund or
that
yeah represent y for our purposes
today rather than say 5050 split we
should recommend to finance the
consideration be given to
blah into the into the distribution
funds like we just did what was the last
bill we just did where we the phology
we did earlier here
today at the beginning something and
just uh uh considering
readjusting the distribution to
two um retirement
that general fund is opposed to group
two I mean because I guess your general
fund it's just a catch all for anything
that the governor wants to or the
finance wants to put it right yeah but
if we if we specify it in here it has to
go
there further on we're setting up a
dedicated fund for that do we want to do
that
though
right
correct right but should we be getting
into the weeds to specifically say we
want to go to group two I mean we should
okay
well we already said oh group two yeah
okay so there is a conflict between what
turnic there's a conflict between what
the governor said in page
think yeah and what she's
[Music]
72 isn't there or no I guess no those
are different those are different things
yeah um yeah she doesn't get into the
there
yeah but that would according
to to our executive director talk um
compensate some in the education trust
fund and again we're only making
recommendations right exactly well given
the recommendation in terms
of the governor's proposal in
hb2 um and this is probably not going to
fly either but I'll make the
recommendation I think uh the
distribution of the education trust fund
uh on lines 13 and 14 should be
higher because in the in the BPT section
on page 72 we're
cutting the share that's going from the
BPT to the education trust fund well
when you say 13 and 14 how can they be
higher they're 50 and 50 well so instead
of saying 5050 I'm talking about like
6040 oh oh okay refer P2 right so what I
what I'm saying Mr chairman is on on
page 42 line 13
and 14 instead of 5050 I would say 60 to
the ETF and 40 to the general fund
because later on her
recommendation I'm not really happy with
either but she's proposing to cut the
share of the BPT that goes to the
education trust fund and I'm I'm hoping
that the director is correct and that
the uh almost $100 million that is being
cut from the education trust fund
according to the distribution will be
made up by additional slot machine
Revenue um my plan B as representative
Elber Berker asked earlier my plan B is
if we make this 60% perhaps we'll close
that
Gap but I think we've got we've got a
history of Court decisions that suggest
don't suggest that that that tell us
that we are we have not been doing our
duty according to funding the education
funding educa public school education in
this state according to the Constitution
um we may well have in the next few
weeks or months more decisions that tell
us the same thing in which case um we're
someplace well it may not be but at
least it's a down payment I
have
sorry anyway that's my opening bid Mr
okay repres S I absolutely want more
money for the educational trust fund but
I think there are a lot of bills and
things mixed in at this point including
a committee focused on this and so I'm
not sure making a small change in this
section is going to really have an
impact wish it would but there's just
too many other things going on
yeah that's a good point there is an
education funding
committee
um well and I don't know that we can I
mean it's not a bad suggestion I just
don't know
that I mean again as I understand it
we're not going to vote on this we're
not we're not making right this is not a
formal vote right so the best that we
can do in this committee I believe is to
perhaps send a message to at least the
finance committee if not the house that
this is what we think um it's symbolic
at best and while it may not solve the
problem and it it it doesn't have the
effect of a committee recommendation and
a floor vote um I do think
that I for one and I think others on
this committee share this view that we
should be making that statement that we
need to we need to do a better job a
funding
problem
new
yes Brier I I I get um I get the
education funding thing but I think
where this is Trail um
House Bill too um I don't know I don't
know if we should be messing with those
percentages okay because the J we have
the problem with the education fund but
we're also going to have a problem
funding General government with the
too
yeah uh represent elme you had a no
that's about
too all right so
oversight represent elberger yeah the
the one answer to the revenue issue is
further
thank okay um so I think uh we are uh a
little bit of an impass on that 50/50
right now I think we just leave it
um this this section that we're looking
at right now ends at line 21 is there
anything else that anyone has wants to
talk about within that
realm
180 there the cuts in in 180 and 181 on
on page 72 I'm not to 72 yet oh you
aren't I'm on page 42 thanks um so we
seem to be so I okay so to summarize
page 42 it's just the first half uh we
we did not make yeah I guess the only
change we made there is we're going to
recommend that there be two to four
licensed charitable organizations for
um the effect of those cuts is to leave
more money in the general fund to be
used for other things
hopefully some of them things that
otherwise would have had to be cut
sand so yeah I I think that's obviously
probably on page 72 that's the most
significant line 26 and line 30 are the
two significant lines that we need to
look at both of those are cutting both
of them cutting the amount to the
education trust funds yes yeah
yeah um by
7%
right so yeah I don't know what the what
is the the main point to that is to put
more in the general fund I
guess yeah it's it's in what is it the
charts from
Dr uh
$95
million coming to the general fund that
was in the education trust fund if we
were in uh what we thought we were going
23 so is my understanding that the
education trust fund right now is is up
by 95 million or
something I don't think so do you
question remember that um they have to
take out money for sped from
that how much I thought it was 50
million but I'm not
sure yeah that's for 2025 so I don't
know if people have put that in the
calculations yet at first the
commissioner of Education wasn't going
to ask for it and now he has asked for
it to be taken out all right I guess can
we have Dr come up for a
minute hour
4:30
today I got my uh I got my response from
Finance as to when they want our
care so I guess the first question for
you is
what is there a is there a positive
balance right now in the education trust
fund I believe the answer to that is yes
I don't have the number because the uh
the Acer hasn't been released yet for
the current year we looked back when we
were waiting uh to see what the balances
had been in years past at the ending
balance of the fund for 2023 it was a
$161 million uh for 2022 it was $108
million um so I don't think it has going
to have
significantly um decreased so much that
there's no balance there this year from
what I've heard through the GD fund it's
around h100 million I don't know how
accurate that is but representative
southworth's
point I heard 100 million before they
deal with the special education
issue has that come to you guys at all
not to me yeah the commissioner may know
but I don't thank you yeah represent UL
real quickly um you're talking about the
variance number over here that's just
the differences in each account so if
this if the other
two uh proposed law takes place you're
taking 94 from one and adding 94 to the
other uh that that's all that is it's
not saying there's a deficit in the
education trust fund of 94,000 that's
correct that it's only the difference on
of the two laws yes our analysis assumed
that going forward the numbers the
revenue numbers would be the same as we
used 2025 plan and using 2025 plan um
$95 million would shift from the ETF to
the the general fund if everything
remains static and people don't do what
people do correct thank
you excuse me can I just ask a question
yes how far off the 25 plan are we
currently about
18% um we also not in our fiscal uh note
for you but um separate and apart from
it we ran yesterday uh numbers based on
the revenue estimating numbers that you
all adopted a few weeks ago if you use
what
you assumed for fiscal 25 26 and 27 um
it looks more like
75 to 80 million depending upon the year
okay 75 to 80 for
what this is where's the year there we
go uh yeah so the fiscal year 25 it's $
75.4 million shift using your Revenue
estimating numbers for fiscal year 26 it
would be a $ 77.2 million shift and
using your Revenue estimating numbers
for fiscal year 27 it would be an even
shift Mr chair may I ask a question and
if we had used the only dissenting vote
that said it was going to be 200 million
out of that total what would be the what
would be the numbers can you in the next
10 minutes as we work on that
why sorry which year are we discussing
uh what year we in 25 20 yeah 25 26 just
the numbers you did just for this past
group y because I had to express that I
thought we were too high on the BPT tax
of over 200 million we should be in the
900 million doll range and this is a 1.1
billion that they're looking at so I
just wonder what the difference would be
yep so um thank you I think the revenue
number that you used was a million or a
billion
30 uh and if you used
900,000 instead for both of the business
ta 900,000 yeah so just for the business
tax sorry for just the business taxes if
let's just assume 900 million the
difference between current law and
million is that not making sense to you
representative shamberg so that the less
shift I also understand Mr chairman that
these numbers here
will not provide the to be less property
tax relief because adequate funding will
go
down and um
that's my position on this
I feel we're we're moving it's amazing
Mr chairman that when I had proposed
this in my other bills they were going
the other direction but I see someone's
taking up that hint of
cutting we are cutting well okay so to
to the getting back to line 26 and line
30 um do we have a different suggestion
than what the governor is suggesting
there
I suggest don't do anything because I
think the corner office is saying we're
going to move this money and property
tax owners are going to have to make up
communities just my
opinion yes represent El me thank you
and I look at this from a different
perspective which is that she's moving
this money to fund things that she
thinks ought to stay alive that aren't
going to stay alive um that she cares
about and I have no idea which ones
those are but I think that the finance
committee needs to make this
decision rather than us so so your
thought is just let them let them figure
that out on point of order yeah just
following up on on her comment really
isn't it their decision no matter what
we say yes yeah oh yeah no we're just so
I guess we're just saying we won't make
any recommendation on that Mr chairman
to that point then why are we here why
did we just spend the last two hours
doing this well we do have a set of
recommendations for them uh they don't
have to take we have a set of
recommendations on everything except
money excuse me Mr chairman it's just
it's just a little frustrating to go
through this process and essentially
arrive at a point where the most
important issue before us is money and
revenue and we
are abandoning our position on
recommendations on money and revenue as
far as I can tell maybe maybe I'm
missing something but um I just feel
like we've wasted the last two
[Music]
hours I don't I don't think so because
uh you know I'm just going back to look
at what we did um
but what the things that we are talking
about Still Still affect money I mean if
you're talking about did we raise money
I mean may maybe we did maybe we didn't
but um you know the the fact that we're
allowing towns to opt in and opt out
that's potentially you know a money
decision for
towns um contributing to group one uh
teachers I think that's that's a money
issue we're looking to uh get more money
into
them well we're we're correct me if I'm
wrong but we're recommending all of
those things correct we we don't have
any power to actually do that we're I
understand and so we're recommending
these things but we're choosing not to
recommend anything on what I think
are the major issues facing this
committee this state our children we're
just saying ah we'll we'll let somebody
else handle that I I just think that's
wrong well we we can make
recommendations what is your
suggestion have you read the entire
budget and do you know what other places
in the budget are being are losing money
or gaining money
because uh of her decisions
because that's where we are this the the
budget committee has to know these
things that's why they divided in three
parts so that they can look at them in
detail on we don't know when we say we
want to put more money into the ETF or
we want to put it into the
GF what that money is allocated to at
the moment and what we lose if we take
it from there to put it somewhere else
well well I I I don't disagree um
representative but I I think essentially
what we're doing here is saying you know
we've got five miles to feed and you
know the fifth one we're just not going
to feed we're making
decisions at the end of the day and I
we've raised this again and again and I
I recognize the other side does not
agree but we we are we are we've raised
the issue it is about Revenue
and and we
have or this body has chosen
to in my opinion make decisions that are
exacerbating the problem and now when we
come to face that fifth
child who's going hungry we're saying
well let's let Finance handle
it no I haven't read the entire budget I
I very honestly I haven't read the
entire budget I do know that
my priorities and the governor's
priorities would be very
different I think to represent El's
point we we have to be careful not to
make a change because yeah my my first
reaction is just leave it at 41 why are
we cutting it but I don't have a global
view I have not read the whole budget I
don't have a global view of the whole
thing so by changing this what are we
then affecting I I I understand your
point I don't disagree with the basics
of your point I just yeah
represent Elber thank you um are are you
in effect saying that what we're looking
at is a zero sum game and we should be
looking
at adding rather than having a zero sum
I think it's worse than a zero sum
game and I would agree with you I mean
in in some CA at least in a zero sum
game you walk away with nothing you know
one party walks away with nothing I
think we're telling one party they're
going to walk away with less than
nothing
well I think on the V I think on the VT
side of things um you know that is that
is one area where we're talking about uh
new Revenue so
um is it a challenging time right now
yes um and uh you know we've got to kind
of walk that walk represent South wor
yeah I'm going to choose my words
carefully um I guess I'd say regrettably
we are a part AR committee and I don't
think we can make big recommendations
when we're missing one two three six
people from one of the parties I just
you know I'm frustrated like many other
people I'd like more Revenue more for
schools and so on but today our task on
this um you know this is where we are
and um for the minority to make some
strong recommendations in this it's not
really giving them the the picture of
the committee with five and actually it
didn't even count um oh so um the people
that are here have a very different
philosophy uh on my side than the people
who are not here who are in the majority
and again to me that's regrettable I
wish it wasn't true but it is true 95%
okay um represent El me yeah I don't
want us to walk away before looking at
page 72 line
23 and at on P line 35
23 Charlie's still
here uh we raised at your request 15
years ago or
something uh up to the the tickets up to
$30 it was a disaster nobody wanted to
buy them oh
50 no and and what now you're trying to
raise it to or someone is trying to
raise it to his
$50 per ticket the question
representative it was not me it was my
predecessor was predecessor it was 2006
oh um that Rick Whistler uh came and
asked R $30 ticket um it wasn't the
price point so much as it was the awful
execution and the launching of it during
the 2007 2008 uh Great Recession uh and
when gas prices spiked and it was all
bad uh and so it hasn't been raised in
17 years and so it's our request to do
it I don't expect I do it the next year
honestly it would probably be the year
two of the bium just because you plan it
out and do it accordingly but I think
we're one of the few states that doesn't
have one and so they're just asking for
the authority that's all great
thanks anything else any other parts of
the
tobacco uh
Revenue um this
is something our committee
does on which they're
changing the division of the tax revenue
by the long term formula that we've had
uh to just being 34% like everybody
else and it's a very minimalist change
um it's um 7824 distribution of funds
line
35 Roman one tax revenue on all tobacco
products sold at retail in the state
imposed by RSA 782 shall be divided with
34% of the total revenue Vue being
deposited in the education trust fund
and the remaining in the general fund
it's only a
difference of oh no it's uh it goes
from um the ETF getting
43. 82% so it isn't minimalist uh
percent of the tobacco Revenue down to
34 so that it will be the same of it as
everybody else um I don't know if we
want to comment on that cuz this weird
formula is the one that the the uh Ways
and Means Committee uh resulted in after
we decided that we had to set the other
tobacco products to the same sales level
as as the um percentage level as as the
says tobacco products which
includes the um non-cigarette
stuff down cigarette stuff non-cigarette
vaping at least I don't think it
includes vaping could piss off a
majority leer include bapy now yeah that
but um unfortunately it would be very
hard to join a
fo
so I don't know what was it before and
we two or three times after that
increased the cigarette tax and that
meant we had to do it by an equivalent
amount which ended up being this
42.8% when we
finished and decided not to do it
again okay
does also take take from the
ETF
so um what do you want to do with that
line well that's the question we don't
have enough here I guess to decide it
but well if we all agree we have enough
here do we want to go with her let's
just do one uniform price acrost
everything that isn't equivalent
um that's what it kind of looks like I
don't know if that's the case that's
what she did 34% for
everything and
it won't work for
it I mean it's kind of the same it's
kind
of have a say in it yeah I mean we can
make a recommendation it's kind of the
same as what you just said earlier about
the
34% of the uh BPT and
bet uh do we have enough contact
to make a decision and we can recommend
something as long as
we it sounds to me like they didn't
really know a whole lot about this they
decided have a uniform tax rate wherever
they
could
possibly parents not well
I have a thought yeah um could we just
have a sentence um similar to what
representative elmy said just at the
very end saying to consider the
breakdown of the different tobacco
34% they're not even um because they're
not breaking them down at all when you
say tobacco product are you including
vaping no no not tobacco no I'm asking
represent self workor um I would um
again say you could put as
consider including vaping or considering
a formula for Vaping something really
represent Aly has better words for it
than I do but I don't think there's any
wrong with asking them to consider
something well they take not much time
to do a lot of work
recommendations
yes microphone microphone
microphone as a nonsmoker I'm not sure
says OTP EIG oh oh yes I don't know how
they
all right so is there any so what do we
want to do with line 26 30 and
um
36 I mean they're all
34% do we want Toad the
di she still
here so what do you want to ask a
question oh oh okay do you have a
question um microphone
please I do have a question on on the
I understand that there's a bill coming
from Lang at some point to us uh that
deals with trying to get a better idea
of what all the Contraband is in in
EIG but this would just refer to the
part that you've been able to get tax
returns from right so again just like we
did with the business taxes we assumed
that uh the all of the three revenue
streams within the tobacco tax would uh
perform according to 2025 plan and this
analysis that we did represents the
shift from the education trust fund to
the general fund for that Revenue stream
it does include the vaping products or
the eigs those currently do not go to
ETF at all yeah and this would shift 34%
of that Revenue to the ETF this does not
touch the rate um of the two types of
vaping products which are different yeah
it just looks at the amount of money
yeah yeah my thought Mr chairman you
just asked about 26 30 and
36 I think we should just recommend they
stay at 41 41 and
43.8 not their their suggestion what is
that last one is it 4 2.8 represent elme
the line 36 where where is line 36 page
72 this thing line 36 oh what's in the
going to the education trust fund right
now yeah that's
so is it 42.8 or what is it I thought
that's what you suggested there
now no but represent El me earlier you
said 42.8 I thought maybe that was
mhm and I'm sorry the stamp sorry yes
the stamp
yeah
yes what percent of all tobacco products
goes to uh the PTO yeah
now so only the stamp Revenue goes to
the ETF currently none of the OT PP or
ecigarette Revenue goes to the ETF
43.8
so if this were to
pass we would then be
taxing
everything and 30 and 34% of everything
we tax would be going to the
ETF
correct you have a different shift for
the two types of products it's a
43.82720 revenue from
cigarettes I think T the tobacco stamp
right for cigarettes only that Revenue a
portion of that gets distributed to the
ETF yes the revenue from vaping
from uh other tobacco products all goes
directly into the general fund correct
the 100% of that goes to the general
fund
yeah that then means that the
department would have to figure out some
way to
tax affirmatively tax The Vape products
we we do currently tax The Vape products
we tax open and closed systems
differently um one is a percentage of
the wholesale price and the other is a
price per milliliter those products are
currently taxed none of the revenue from
those products goes to the ETF currently
the language in hb2 doesn't imp the rate
of tax at all it only impacts how much
is distributed to which of the
funds okay so that's so yeah so that's
increasing the rate of distribution into
the TF front from other tobacco products
correct yes but you're also
cutting the rate of distribution from
the tobacco from cigarettes so if you
look at the sh at the chart from Dr if
you look at the page page where is
it if you look at at page three it's not
numbered but if you look at page three
hb2
would
uh would cost the ETF distribution would
would uh decrement the ETF distribution
by $18 million based on current
numbers but it would add because it
would now have a distribution for vaping
and for other tobacco products it would
add
9.9
million resulting in a
total uh decrement to the education
trust fund of 8.1 million is that am I
reading your chart correctly you have it
correct yes so in the end what hb2 is
proposing with the tobacco tax with the
other tobacco products tax with the
business profits tax with the be
with everything else is to cut education
the education trust fund by n about $95
million based on
plan all four taxes combined assuming
plan is the revenue base we use you're
correct right if you go to the last page
of that of that
chart the education trust fund would
under hb2 education trust fund would
lose 61.7
million uh from BPT based compared to
the current law all right that would
lose $26.5 million from the current you
know based on the current law from
BET and then it would lose about $8
million from tobacco
products no no no I total in other words
it loses $18 million from the tobacco
stamp from cigarettes but it gains
9.9 by Distributing Revenue for vaping
and for other tobacco products into ETF
resulting in a net loss to ETF from all
tobacco products vaping cigarettes
everything of about 8.1
million and then I guess it
gains 1.4 million from a change in the
real estate transfer tax and I didn't
look at what the change is but at any
rate it the the total is a net l loss to
the education trust fund based on
current law of
94.9
million which in my view is going in
direction I'm wondering if that's a
result and I have no idea whether that's
a result of the fact that the as I've as
I've heard the education trust fund is
running at about close to 100 million
ahead maybe that's why she's chosen to
do this um I I don't know just a
thought but given given where we are now
I mean we need to wrap up we another
couple people had to leave because of
timing um I I unless someone has a
concrete reason for changing this right
anything this is from the governor
correct and it's we're sending it over
to finance yeah it's going to get why
don't we just let go back to the
original numbers 4141 whatever and let
Finance make that deter our
recommendation be we stay at 41
41 and whatever Susan has ranking member
had said it was 43.8 whatever that was
and just let Finance then take the
H if they make a
the recommendation on page 72 is to go
back to the
4141 43.8 I think is
what okay great anything
else
okay okay
um even though on the last page Mr
chairman I see they're going to charge
the counties more in the long run I
think on on line four on the page 7 3 it
looks to me like the housing
fund is no
longer
funded which um I
don't because that's that I mean I
looked it up that's what that is RSA 78
B13 is money going to the housing fund
so it seems like the housing fund's
going away um so maybe
maybe am
it's it's only five million yeah should
we so do we want to recommend that we
not do that yeah we might as well we
don't care I mean we're Revenue they us
not distribution that's a distribution
argument yeah that's true that's true
that's just the back half of that's
that's a good point that's actually not
our not our committee yeah okay um all
right so I'm going to close the uh work
session on
hb2 and and uh so for next week for
those of you wondering what we're doing
next week representative
SP okay next week we'll probably I'm
probably scheduling Tuesday the 18th
Tuesday Yeah Tuesday the 18th Tuesday
that yeah I didn't want to schedule
today M today we had a problem with
people being able to attend but this you
know tomorrow's election day and the
speaker asked us not to schedule
meetings on Tuesday because ordinar I
would have scheduled it tomorrow um so
anyways that's uh yeah so I'll schedule
I don't know what's going to be on the
schedule yet other than there's I think
there's two or three new bills we're
going to have to have public hearings on
so there'll be public hearings I
think yeah well we we are debating is it
three new ones or four and minus one I
don't know so we're gonna have I think
there's only two new bills we'll have
public hearings on those
we'll um I don't know what to do with uh
728 um we could do a work session on
that um the following week is the last
week we have to get well yes all the
I'll have to look at that if there's a
bill that has to be out by uh the 20th
then we have to exec that next week um
and then there's a couple those second
committee bills that we got we could
actually exect those the following week
I won't be here that following week the
20 whatever it is 5th 6 26th Jordan will
probably chair the meeting and it
probably will just consist of executing
one or two bills so I I it's probably a
half a day meeting but anyways that's so
that's pretty much a schedule as far as
I can see right now probably Tuesday the
18th and probably do you prefer Tuesday
the 25th 10 o' yeah yeah
and 25th uh is the Tuesday yeah yeah
yeah so probably the Tuesday and Tuesday
starting at 10 o'clock and I won't be
here for the second Tuesday um but we'll
still have a meeting we'll see how
Jordan
does he'll do he'll do
fine whatever whatever you feel needs to
be done no I preer